Doo doo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Boom.
Yes.
We're live.
Hello,
Eric.
Hello Joe.
Thanks for doing this,
man.
I'm.
Jamie had a question.
You're,
you're not related to that.
Other fellow to other one team fell.
It's in trouble right now.
Bret Weinstein.
No.
That's your brother.
The other guy.
Weinstein or the other guy?
Yeah.
I don't know him.
Okay.
That other guy's in trouble.
Like two more women.
Angelina Jolie and they both came out
today.
Yeah.
I don't think it's going to stop there.
Uh,
seems like you might've had a little bit
of an issue and that amazing that
someone can get away with something like
that for so long and then one or two
people come clean and the walls come
down.
The oppressive fist of just his fucking
tyranny,
whatever that guy did.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think it does speak to the idea that
power really exists in an industry in a
town like this.
It's always been the.
That's been the Cliche,
right?
The casting couch,
Yes.
But I didn't know in the modern era how
much,
uh,
how much power any still had.
Yeah.
I wonder,
you know,
it's just,
and it's also like super left wing guy,
you know,
like really politically connected to
social justice ideologies,
fighting gun control.
I mean,
you know,
promoting gun control and stumping for
Hillary and all this.
Yeah,
it seems like overcompensation.
I didn't want to bring this up right up
front about that.
We were going to talk about cuddle fish.
I asked you to save the cuttlefish and
just cuddled conversation about little
fish.
Well,
we were talking about,
I mean all of these are just incredible
hot button topics,
but we were talking before about your
Ra,
your conversation on um,
male and female programming in the mind
on male and female,
a biological frames.
And what I was,
what I was going to talk about there was
that you can actually have in other
species which aren't nearly as
controversial as humans.
I'm irrational basis for something like
transphobia in an evolutionary context.
So the giant cuttle fish,
which I think is called Sepia Pama.
I'm not a biologist.
I'm the males are incredibly large.
They're very sexually dimorphic and
you've got these tiny or smaller males
who don't have a good strategy for
keeping a lot of females underneath them
were so the males are incredibly larger
that females are incredibly large.
The females tend to be much smaller when
the females are impressed.
They accept shelter underneath one of
these giant males,
but then you have these other males who
aren't nearly as big,
um,
which might be called sneaker males.
And the sneaker males start retracting
the tentacles that identify them as male
and changing through their chromatin
fours.
They're sort of their presentation to
look female.
And then the giant males invite these
males disguised as females through
behavioral change underneath.
And we've now proven,
I believe that these sneaker males
inseminate the females.
Well,
the larger males are getting duped now.
Are the larger males larger because they
just have better genetics or are they
larger because they're older?
Well,
you know,
the question about better genetics.
Key question is who leaves the lineages
that matter over time?
So if you're wasting all of your energy
on a strategy,
and in fact what you're doing is you're
providing protection for sneaker males
to get busy with the females who seemed
to be equally happy to reward a devious
male as a strong one.
You know,
I'm a put in mind of the old,
the Willie Dixon Blues Song.
I'm a backdoor man.
The men don't know,
but the little girls understand,
um,
you know,
definitely a female's favor.
A variety of strategies,
whether communicating strengthened,
dominance,
cleverness,
a or anything that females are likely to
decide,
uh,
will benefit their offspring.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a great name for them to sneaker
males.
Is that like the tactical mail at the
technical term for those small males?
I've seen it in lizards and I don't know
the Sepia Pama giant cuttle fish system,
but I'm,
I'm obsessed with cephalopod,
so I should probably go back and do some
homework on them.
I didn't know we would be starting out
with Harvey Weinstein again.
Giant,
giant cuttle fish Weinstein versus
Weinstein.
That's the difference.
I'm definitely keeping that distinction.
Yeah,
it's a good distinction now.
Right now.
It's good to make a separation.
So I'm cephalopods including cuttlefish
octopus,
squids,
novelists,
and then they all sort of came from
mollusks,
right?
This is the craziest thing in the world,
I mean,
we're not,
we're not guaranteed to meet an alien
intelligence during our lifetimes,
but the idea that such genius exists in
mollusks where you least expect it and,
um,
is probably the closest we're ever going
to get to aliens.
So,
I mean,
I think that it's sort of,
there's a secret,
uh,
international conspiracy,
um,
people who have realized this and,
you know,
just freak out on cephalopods and they
know,
they know every crazy thing that
cephalopods have been proven to,
to understand and um,
you know,
where their cognitive capabilities,
uh,
just sort of wow us,
have the cognitive capabilities,
their camouflage capabilities,
the strategies that they use for
attacking a bait fish.
And there's a video that I put up on my
twitter really recently have a cuddle
fish that opens up like a flower and
shoots its tongue out and gets this fish
and then just sucks it into his body.
And it's like you're looking at some
kind of an alien that's totally an mean,
I forget,
is that like seven fold symmetry or you
know,
it's really on a different branch of the
phylogenetic tree and I think that the
dazzled patterns where you just start
seeing these neon signs that are
effectively made out of the chromatin
fours and if you've seen the videos
where people put them on against like
really artificial patterns like chess
boards or Chins are things and the
cuttlefish has to figure out,
okay,
how do I blend in with that?
Yeah.
And they do their best to market,
but the natural world,
they mimicked perfectly well not really.
I think was it octopus can do it,
some octopus can do it.
I think what happens is the pie.
Yeah,
that's,
I don't know that one.
Um,
I guess it's Octopi.
I think what they do is they actually
sort of do much less than we are
imagining.
And they used the fact that we,
our brains are interpolated.
So they're in part,
not matching the background as well as
we think,
but they're doing it well enough that
our brains sort of make up the
difference.
That's weird.
I mean,
but what,
what would be the difference between the
way we interpret their,
their visual,
uh,
what,
whatever camouflage they're giving off
because it's a visual camouflage,
right?
Yeah.
If you look at some of the,
uh,
some of the camouflage videos,
like the first seven times you see it,
you can't imagine.
Yeah.
Uh,
but then after,
after awhile you say,
Oh wow,
there really is a difference.
And Somehow,
um,
I just,
I did the interpolation to help out that
which is trying to escape my detection.
Well,
I mean there's definitely a distinction
you can kinda tell once you look at it,
but it's so insanely impressive and
comparison to pretty much,
almost every other life form.
You know,
what they can do in terms of like they
could change their texture.
That's one of the,
like when they,
when they sit on a coral reef and they
start looking like a coral reef,
like,
whoa.
Have you,
uh,
have you checked out the mimic octupus?
Yes.
Right.
So that one,
five or six different disguises.
Yeah.
Uh,
I,
I can't even imagine that.
Usually when you have mimicry,
it's dedicated or obligate like a,
you know,
a stick bug or a leaf insect.
It's only going to do that one trick.
You,
you know,
what's interesting too is like I've
heard a real legitimate argument for
people that are opposed to eating animal
protein that a mollusks especially like
clams and mussels and things along those
lines are more primitive
in terms of their ability to recognize
or have any,
any sense of what pain is,
any sort of communication,
any sort of interpretation of danger
that all they do is just close.
Right.
And that in closing we've interpreted
that to being an animal and that this
animal life form is like,
it's like eating a living thing versus
like eating plants.
But I've heard it argued it actually.
Sam Harris was the first one to bring it
up.
This is actually a moral argument that
they sense less than plants do and that
they are more,
they're more primitive than plants are,
but yet from the [inaudible] family,
you have octopus and there's a good
argument that you probably shouldn't be
knocked a post.
Like you shouldn't beat monkeys,
you know,
like an octopus is fucking smart.
Like crazy.
Sneaky.
Smart.
It's them or us,
Joe.
Oh,
that's good.
I mean,
in that case they are delicious.
Yeah.
I think if you ever look at Humboldt
Squid,
um,
you know,
schooling and descending as one of the
greatest nightmares of all time.
I think I've seen a humboldt squid as a
humboldt squid sometimes if we get.
They called the red devils are the coast
of Baja California and they're just
social in.
They're terrifying because they attack
in groups.
So the planet or the coordinate in some
way
in some way.
I mean,
obviously the chromatophores must have
some ability to do signaling.
And I think that with respect to w,
we have to figure out,
um,
whether it's really intelligence that
causes us to become empathic because
obviously if you're at war and you think
highly of your enemy,
you have to guard against your own
empathy so that you can be an effective
warrior.
You have to ask the question,
uh,
you know,
if monkeys and apes are among the most
intelligent beings,
do I actually feel some revulsion for
just how savage chimpanzees are as
compared to say bonobos are givens.
Yeah.
Isn't that the real argument or the,
the real fascinating conversation is
what happened on in the evolutionary
chain.
Like why did banabos become these
peaceful sexual creatures and champs
become these warring savage psychos,
like what they look so similar.
Like what happened?
Well,
that,
that one,
no,
but there's an interesting system in
Dung.
Beetles were,
um,
if you look at the armaments that they
have on their head,
um,
uh,
for warring between males,
there's a conserved quantity between the
length of the Copula Tory apparatus and
the size of the weaponry.
So the more weapons,
the smaller the penises.
And so,
you know,
there are all these crazy tradeoffs in
apes between relative testicular size,
in peanut size
for gorillas,
gorillas have tiny little
penises,
but enormous bodies and giant fangs and
tiny penis.
Yeah,
I guess.
Yeah.
And chimpanzees have big penises and
testicles both.
Yeah.
See they said that chimpanzees,
there's a direct correlation between
promiscuous females and the size of
their testicles.
Hmm.
I don't,
I don't remember that one.
But yeah,
the question about.
I also worry that we've,
um,
we've idealized the banabos too much and
you know,
we were sort of,
it's very hard to be empathetic with the
chimps after Jane Goodall showed us what
they're capable of.
Um,
but in part,
uh,
you know,
the,
the cold logic of the natural world,
um,
in general,
you know,
it's usually some reason that makes
complete sense.
It's,
it can't be sentimental anytime you
bring sentimentality,
uh,
and you usually screw up a good theory.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I,
I worry that our comparisons are driven
by our needs to,
to locate ourselves a farther away from
chimpanzees and closer to something that
we,
we feel comfortable.
So are idealizing the Banabos is not
necessarily based on what they actually
are,
but based on like our little sort of
hippie version of life,
like,
look,
we could be like the banabos loving and
sexual and affectionate,
or we can be like the warring horrible,
horrible chimpanzees.
Well,
you know,
it's also the case that,
uh,
how great does it feel to be sexual if
you're being sexually out competed by
others?
It's always unfunded to be,
you know,
low status and nature has different ways
of punishing and rewarding a status and
achievement in,
in various,
uh,
the various different species.
So my guess is,
is that there is a kind of concise
conserved,
um,
you know,
unpleasantness and losing each
particular game and a pleasure and
winning each particular game.
And that's,
that's essentially how nature keeps
moving forward.
Right?
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
to the extent that,
uh,
you're wasting energy.
I'm warring when you could be being
constructive or being more strategic,
uh,
you're going to get out competed by
whichever,
uh,
members,
of your species,
you know,
figure out the puzzle first.
And so I think that,
um,
you know,
there's this concept of the naturalistic
fallacy of,
of viewing that which,
uh,
you know,
if you assume that we carry some sort of
Judeo Christian baggage and all of this,
uh,
was thought to come from a,
a creator who was thought to have
positive characteristics than,
well,
obviously the natural world is God's
work.
But I mean if you actually look at the
systems that fascinate me,
the creator would have to be about the
most twisted consciousness.
A consciousness you could possibly
imagine.
Well,
it seems like it's,
it's the long game.
The creators playing the creators not
playing the game that favors the,
the health and the welfare of the
individual.
And the current day.
It's the matter of like figuring out how
to get through this brutal game and
advancing and evolving along the way to
the point where some day in the future
you find a more complex and evolving
system.
But this is
the most complex and evolved.
This us,
you and me,
humans,
most complex and evolved system in terms
of its ability to change its environment
that we've ever come across.
And we're not too happy with ourselves.
Yeah.
Although I do think that despite our
barbarism,
we are that which can contemplate the
game and you know,
at some point you've obviously had my
brother on the street on the show.
I asked him as an evolutionary
theorists,
Brett,
what are you doing?
You know,
you're married to one woman and you've
had two kids,
uh,
as an evolutionary theorists,
don't you think you're throwing the
game?
And his response was,
I think,
brilliant.
It was a.
and tell me,
Eric,
if you understood the game,
why would you want to continue to play
it?
Right?
So for him it was almost like a sort of
proof that,
um,
if you really get,
you know,
another one of his good quotes is that a
life when properly understood is a
spelling bee that ends in genocide.
That we're also focused on our
nucleotide sequences.
Do you really care about the particular
way in which you did digest lactose?
Uh,
different from how I do it that you want
to go to war with me.
So we can spell the future using your
version rather than mine.
Maybe you,
you'd feel this way about your ideas,
about,
you know,
your songs,
your stories,
but really you really want to fight over
like things that neither of us care
about.
Like what,
what are you saying?
Well,
if you're trying to think about like,
I want to leave seven children,
okay,
why do you want to do that?
Well,
because I want to see more copies of
myself.
Well you will see a certain number of
copies of yourself,
but that's going to get diluted very
quickly by the time we get to your
great,
great grandchildren's can be hard to see
yourself in your offspring.
So that's sort of an illusion of one
generation,
two generations.
Most of the things that are going to
determine your genes a propagating.
I'm have to do with the fact that you're
on a team.
There are a bunch of people who digest
milk the way you do.
And so the key question is,
you know,
team Rogan on the milk digestion is some
huge number of people you've never met.
That's what I understand.
Like why I don't understand the
connection to milk digestion.
It's just one thing that your body is
doing in a particular way.
So,
you know,
like,
let's
take eichler maybe that's more familiar.
So,
you know,
I,
I know that I have a blue illegal that
is being suppressed in terms of its
expression.
Do I really care that um,
you know,
if my wife has two brown illegals,
um,
does it matter to me that my blue
somehow survives?
Do I care that I want it to survive
enough against some brown eyed person?
It'd be interesting if you had a
checklist of like what things that you
would agree upon,
like you and the wife get together,
say,
okay,
so,
uh,
this ability,
what do you think?
You know,
who's who side?
We go on with intelligence.
You're a little smarter than me.
I'm going to give it to you.
Let's go with.
Let's go with your brains.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm better at smelling things like,
how do you.
I'm just allergic to cats.
Let's have none of the kids fucking
sneeze.
Every time they go near a litter box was
the great thing was just flip a coin.
Yeah,
let's do it a couple of times and
whatever we get we get.
I,
I worry about a crispr cas,
nine people are going to be having
these,
like,
I'll trade you this for that.
We're gonna have crazy.
Yeah,
I'm fascinated by crispr.
I mean I think most people aren't even
aware of it.
People like you of course are people who
are paying attention are,
but I think to the general public has no
idea that crispr even exists and it's
potentially world changing.
I mean you're literally looking at the
tools that will eventually lead.
Much like,
you know,
Alexander Graham Bell's invention led to
you having the Internet in your pocket.
Right?
Slowly but surely.
I mean,
you,
you're looking at the tools that will
one day lead to us engineering some
completely new organism that you're
going to call human beings.
Yeah.
I think that's going to be a long time
off.
Alexander Graham Bell was a long time
off and I think,
well,
I bet it's less time than that.
Okay.
When was that?
Was the 18 hundreds?
What are the odds?
Two thousand 17 to the late 18 hundreds.
You don't take 21 slash 17,
we're going to behave a fucking
incredible hulks and thor's and women
look like wonder woman.
There's not going to be a single troll
like looking person left and the one
that I think we're going to be able to
do a lockdown.
Yeah,
I think we're going to be able to do a
lot more competent torics of swapping
something in that's known to work and
swapping something out.
But when we actually get to like
authorship,
we were like,
okay,
I got this great idea for a human being.
I'm going to start from scratch.
Uh,
there's a lot of optimism that,
um,
for which I am the pessimist,
you know,
uploading the mind to a computer.
Yeah.
You pet Kurzweil's ideas.
Well,
not in the sense that we're never going
to get anywhere close,
but just 1:45.
That's what they're aiming for.
I mean,
I'm optimistic about certain things that
turned out to be a lot easier than we
expected.
I think that a lot of things that are or
we thought were going to require
artificial general intelligence are
going to succumb to much simpler systems
and so you know,
you might've thought that,
for example,
if you played through the great chess
games,
have a,
you know,
the 18 hundreds,
like morphe in Anderson and things,
you might say,
well that's just a uniquely human
activity and then you find out,
no,
no computers can trounce humans at chess
because it's not.
It wasn't what you thought it was.
Maybe music will be the next thing to
succumb because that's really highly
regular,
but music is also intensely creative and
emotive,
right?
It,
it,
it sparks feeling in humans and,
and I don't think you could really,
I don't know.
I mean maybe you could,
but I don't think you really could
figure out a way to engineer or have a
computer engineer something that makes
you feel like led Zepplin the immigrant
song.
You know,
there's just like a bizarre feeling to
someone's art that comes through when
you listened to it and you're like,
oh,
this is a fucking great.
You know,
like where I don't,
I don't necessarily know you could do
that with something that doesn't
understand emotions or is using a
replica of emotions.
Whereas chess,
you know,
a rook move this way upon can move that
way.
Here's the rules.
This is how it starts.
This is what once you get here,
you're in check.
Like those things seem pretty
straightforward.
You're dealing with squares.
It's very mathematic.
You know,
one person moves in,
another one moves.
Whereas like there's like this fluid
nature to art literature and music and
the other half of that I think I
disagree.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
so I don't know why you chose the
immigrant that that's why,
because I'm going to go to cryotherapy
after this.
That's the domino's to do.
It's just a good song.
So if we,
if you'd taken,
if you'd,
if you'd taken a Roy orbison's pretty
woman.
Okay.
Right.
So do you have the main riff from that
song had like walking down the street
due to come to America or that we're
going after the um,
the riff is like,
dude,
dude did it.
Who Do do it?
It,
it,
it did it right,
so if you start,
if you take a guitar string and you
split it into four equal parts,
you put your finger over a one quarter
of the string and then you start just
plucking a string and hovering above the
string so you don't actually push it to
the fret board.
Those notes occur naturally as the
harmonics in the expansion of the
vibrating string so that those notes
were not really chosen by Roy orbison or
whoever wrote the song.
They were really chosen by like a four
day series and it feels like it's a,
a rift.
But I discovered this when I was in
Indonesia as I would start playing that
and people would react and I felt like
why that song?
What about more complex creative and
sort of improvisational song like food
who child from Hendrix.
So I don't know
about Voodoo child.
What I mean take take.
It changes up.
So if you look at the first couple of
cords of red house,
there's like some seventh or diminished
chord,
like he's arpeggiated Nana,
and then he moves it down a half step,
which has to do with this tritone
substitution and the symmetry inside of
the seventh chord.
So if I recall correctly,
you have a chord like C,
e,
g,
b flat would be a c seven chord and the
e and the b flat would form this thing
called a triton.
And now if you went in the blues,
you,
there are three elements of the chord
progression,
the dominant subdominant and the tonic.
If you go down a half step,
you effectively invert the third in the
flat seventh.
Uh,
so if you go one half step below that,
it's the flat seventh and the third I
think,
of the subdominant court.
So Hendrix is actually playing with math
in something as basic as.
Do you think he's aware of it or do you
think he's doing it sort of just
instinctual?
Well,
first of all,
when you're visited by an alien
intelligence,
we went through cuddle fish and we now
we've gotten into Jimi Hendrix,
so that's like,
these are the,
these are the best alien sightings we
have.
It's very hard to speculate,
but I,
I,
I just look at everything I've been able
to understand about what he did and you
know,
you're dealing with a supermind as well
as an intuitive mastery,
mastery of the instrument,
complete understanding of the chords and
progressions and just the ability to
improvise and to make it sound
different.
Adding the Wah Wah pedal and all that
distortion and all the shit that he used
and the fact that he imparts more into
one note,
like,
I wouldn't even know how to notate mean
what is even the instrument.
You didn't play the guitar.
He played the guitar amplification.
You signal processing system as a whole.
Yeah.
So there are these people who are just
in some multidimensional space.
Another one of my favorites is a guy
named Roy Buchanan,
who somehow these guys who understand
harmonics gravitate to telecasters and
um,
you know,
pull a song called Roy's blues and watch
him just go into the multiverse and
start playing with things that you can't
even imagine are possible.
So I do think that there's a very close
relationship between algorithms and
emotion and I just did this one for an
old tweet of mine where I wrote a python
program that actually runs from the
tweets of the entire program is in the
tweet and it's purpose is to generate
the chord progression for Pachelbel's,
which is if you want people to cry at a
wedding,
that's the chord progression to play.
And so the idea that it's actually an
algorithm that breaks your heart,
it is very frightening.
Uh,
just
some insane noise in the background here
folks.
They're doing some shit to our roof.
These are the last days that were in the
studio by the way,
which is hilarious that it's sort of
highlighting why we need to get the fuck
outta here.
But I don't know what they're doing to
this.
I mean,
does he even ran anymore?
Why will they do with fixing the roof?
Put a fucking top up their assholes.
The guy even asked me right before the
show,
he's like,
what time do you take?
I told him,
it's like,
oh,
well that's right about the time we're
letting explosions right above your
head.
Sorry for people listening to this.
Like,
what the fuck is that noise?
That's the noises banging around the
roof pinned down by enemy fire.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I think it's also me as a,
as a human,
I probably have some bias,
some stupid idea that creativity is
impossible to recreate.
You know that whatever it leads to a
person being able to make some beautiful
song or create some amazing book is
impossible for some sort of a computer
to figure that out on its own.
Well,
if you've.
I would go ahead and hang out in a
modern recording studio and watch the
move the beat around and mutated and
change it.
Or if you think about like that moment
where share said,
hey,
I don't think autotune should be used to
correct my voice in a sly way,
I'm going to use this as the instrument
itself and suddenly this metallic voice
I'm actually isn't,
becomes an anthem.
And you start,
you know,
Robo share is incredibly inspiring.
Do you remember a Peter Frampton,
he was one of the first guys to use it
in a song.
Do you feel like I do.
So he used that thing with his mouth.
They had a tube in his mouth.
So he's really actually using his body
to shape.
He's using the,
it's like this five dimensional lattice
in your,
in your mouth to produce the
international phonemic alphabet.
So your,
your nose could be on or off.
That's one degree of freedom.
You can have vocalization on or off
vocalization,
meaning you can have.
You're like F,
F,
F as in Frank Versus v as in victory.
They're the same mouth,
right?
But right.
So you just vibrating your throat so you
can have no vocalization.
So is in the throat somewhere.
Frank,
you fucking boomer like s versus z would
be another pair.
Okay,
so the sound that you're making with
your throat and then you have like your
lips and one of three positions.
So that's a third degree of freedom than
your tongue can be in one of five
positions and it can be fully elevated,
half elevated or not elevated at all.
So there's like five parameter family
that generates what's called the
international phonemic alphabet.
And um,
you know,
one of the cool things to think about is
how could you create an instrument that
naturally allowed you phonemic
productions that you're not just doing
these simple ringing tones?
Well,
there's gotta be a way to just recreate
it physically,
right?
That just make an artificial head and
maybe we just made an artificial head
with.
I mean,
it's not like we do something that's
impossible to recreate with a robot.
Okay.
But like in terms of if you take the
collection of all major instruments,
what comes closest to the human voice?
A lot of people think it's the,
uh,
Indian violin called the Sarangi.
Really?
Yeah.
You never check that out.
What's a Sarangi?
A Sarangi is like a.
can we use it to drown out the pounding
on the roof?
We'd win a Sarangi yeah.
I've never even heard of it.
It sounds bad ass.
It's so.
It's a strange.
Violin is a strange violence.
A lot of sympathetic strings and um,
you know,
because of you can power into a note.
You if you,
if I have a guitar and I pluck a string,
I'm just going to get decay unless I
drive the sound right.
But if I do with my voice.
Oh look how cool that thing looks.
Yeah.
Wow.
Louder.
Just trying to imagine like a lot of
those are sympathetic strings.
So they ring when you hit the tone
perfectly.
Whoa.
Let me see.
So if you've never gotten into north
Indian classical music,
this is today's your lucky day.
This is really cool.
It's wild looking thing,
man.
It only has three strings.
Yeah.
My guess is,
I mean I don't recall,
but very often you will need to know
what that one looks kind of old.
It looks beat up fucking amazing.
You felt amazing rum.
Know Ryan on this thing.
He was like the ultimate,
ultimate Badass and the Sarangi I'm
learning,
so almost died out.
It almost died.
I think it was like,
it was used for guzzle singing and
courtesans used to play it.
What's that guzzle singing guzzles like
his type of,
uh,
of song that would be popular in what
would now be Pakistan in northern India
funded Drumna Ryan decided to check this
dude out.
Do you remember Zam fear?
Master of the pamphlet.
Have those late night ads.
Remember that?
That should have died off quicker.
I am that old.
That
pamphlet thing really never caught on.
This is way better than the pamphlets.
Do you think this guy has groupies?
I know he does.
Does he teach yoga too?
It seems like you would.
Um,
well,
so you see the drums on the left or
right?
Yeah.
So that's
the tabla and the [inaudible] and that
is the,
you know,
I think many people would consider north
Indian drumming to be the world's most
advanced rhythmic system.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
even,
even more than Africa.
Um,
the speed of articulation,
it goes at the speed of speech and if
you take the Hindi verb to speak bold,
they have the system that they call the
bowls and to speak the bowls is to say
what you would instruct your hands to do
if you were playing.
Wow.
Look at him.
I've heard sounds like this before for
sure.
Like A,
I'm a fan of dollar mandate,
like dollar Mindy's music.
Okay.
Let's get some cool music and he has
this kind of shit in the background a
lot.
Do you know who he is?
Right?
I do not.
You don't know who dollar Mendez I
should.
What is the song?
The big famous song?
A thing?
It's called Tunic tunic tune.
It's really a bad ass song.
It's a,
I really love music where I don't know
what they're saying.
You know,
I,
I enjoy that because it's just like,
you just kinda get a feel for the song.
You have no idea what the actual words
where they could be totally corny.
You know?
See if you can find some
thing like speaking the bowls for Tabla
and you'll see these guys doing this
thing where they decorated the tree,
didn't know that.
You know what they do,
places that they create with their
mouths,
everything that their fingers would do
with their hands so they can act that
song,
that song.
We were just playing what's totally cut
off this business.
He's got a bad ass.
I have no idea what he's saying.
You guys hilarious music video too.
The music is like,
it's not bad ass.
It's him against him in this video,
but he arrested for like a white
slavery.
Well that's good.
Yeah.
He got arrested.
Jesus.
What?
It was like sex trafficking or something
like that.
Some kind of slave trade,
sex slave trafficking or something like
that.
He was a part of some,
I don't know,
maybe he just pissed off the wrong guy
in India and I guess they'd fucking hit
him with some bullshit charge.
You never know.
You know?
Weird countries like that.
They can get away with a lot of shit.
What does it brother just died?
I guess that's taking over the news on
his name.
Anyway.
Sorry.
So,
um,
what does that do?
Those drums called again,
often just called tableau,
but tableau is the sort of soprano drum
and then the,
the beyond,
I guess you play with sort of the heel
of your hands.
You strike it and go,
Huh.
And I think the,
you know,
the world's best practitioner is this
guy lives in marine county now,
soccer Hussein,
who's the child of America who was like
the bad ass of his time and it's one of
these things where I think you sort of
have to be born almost into the family
to have this passed down.
How do you know all this stuff?
This is something you've studied for a
long time.
There is an amazing book by guy named
Neil Surreal that I picked up in college
and I just opened it up and it went
through an entire performance,
uh,
of Indian,
north Indian classical music.
And I was just,
you know,
my jaw was on the floor.
How has the entire form of classical
music much closer to our jazz.
So much more impressive.
I mean,
visually to watch one of these drummers
and one of these soloists,
the soloists,
we'll try to lose the drummer and the
drummer's got these mirror neurons that
can't be beat and he'll just like follow
him everywhere and so you're just,
you know,
some,
a poor white kid in America saying,
nobody told me this existed.
Yeah,
it's weird how we just choose a certain
series of instruments that represent
rock and roll certain series of
instruments that represent jazz.
You know,
it's really strange when you think of
the wide range of musical instruments
that exist all over the world that are
just never utilized in modern music.
Yeah.
And I do think that we've become too
complacent.
We should be like Ian Anderson with
Jethro Tull.
Why?
If you listen to the flute Solo and
locomotive breath,
that'll get me going every God damn
time.
And why didn't I take,
I didn't take it off.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
uh,
the clarinet was lost to jazz,
used to be this incredibly dominant
instrument and coming out of the Klezmer
tradition,
you know,
it rocked and then it sort of became
this non thing.
And at some point I saw a guy named Tony
Scott who was like the last great
clarinetist and jazz who went off to
Japan to study zen for years and he came
back for a birthday concert and he blew
dizzy Gillespie and Benny Carter off the
stage.
I was just thinking like,
oh,
I forgot.
Clarinet can be the kick kickass
instrument.
Yeah.
Most people think of it as something
you're forced to take in high school.
Yeah.
But fundamentally that's where like the
youth,
the Ukulele has come back like crazy.
The UKULELE was a Mexican instrument
that was introduced to Hawaii.
Right?
Isn't that what your gaze?
I think,
but it got an.
It's a,
a big thing
in Hawaii,
right?
Are they into the Ukulele?
I think it came over with cattle
ranchers.
I think it was introduced to Hawaii by
people who brought over like cowboys,
like if I remember,
I might be butchering the story.
So forgive me my Hawaiian friends.
But I think what it,
what it was was they had introduced
cattle at some point in the history of
Hawaii and when they introduced cattle,
they're like,
hey,
uh,
how do you keep these fucking things
from wandering all over the place?
So man,
we got to find some cowboys,
teach us how to do this shit.
And they got some,
it was either Mexican or South American
cowboys to come over and show them how
to wrangle these cows,
how to,
how to corral them,
how to take care of them.
And then when they did these cowboys
came over and introduced the Ukulele,
which is really kind of uniquely
Hawaiian in art in America.
When we think about it,
you know,
you hear like a sound of the Ukulele.
We,
we sort of think about it as well,
like my daughter's a musician and when
we're in Hawaii I got her Ukulele.
Like she,
you,
she plays it.
We think about it.
It's like in a lot of people's eyes,
like a lot of like what we think of as
classic Hawaiian Music is played with a
Ukulele.
Really?
Yeah.
So I think I'm going to fuck up that
history was I thought it was like a
portrait.
I think it's Oakland Lily.
It's like jumping flee.
So it's on wine name on a Portuguese
instrument.
What's that?
That's it.
Make a pdf says they attributed to a
three Portuguese immigrants and the 18
eighties that developed it from three
other guitar lick instruments from
Portugal.
Quality Cava keynote.
That's the origin of the Ukulele.
But how did it get to Hawaii as they
were in Hawaii?
Oh,
they were in Hawaii.
Those guys were in Hawaii.
Oh.
So they brought it to a why the guys who
made it?
That's what wikipedia says.
So,
but it's not wikipedia.
I'll say Brian Collins,
my brother and I have some weird
diseases that I don't really have.
Pt is awesome.
I just love the fact that he's led
people just edit it.
Like anytime there's a podcast and
something fucked up happens,
you go to the person's wikipedia page
and they'll totally butcher it.
Well,
the amazing thing is is that it works at
all.
Yes.
That's it.
That is amazing.
It is amazing.
I never would have guessed that.
Yeah,
right.
Like some user edited thing that sort of
what,
what's amazing also because there's only
one snopes,
you know,
like there's only one like real well
regarded fact checking website.
Like someone will say like,
Hey,
I want you to snopes that.
Right.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't anymore.
I'm distressful.
You'd stressed about distrustful,
distrustful of snopes.
Why?
Why do you feel like they're left
leaning or do you feel like they're just
not necessarily 100 percent honest or
what do you think well,
or do you think the guide gets a lot of
hookers and blow and not really pay
attention.
Sometimes guys,
the history of it,
it's fucking hilarious guy.
He just shacks up with some escort and
she becomes the main editor.
I'm going to have some more dmt before.
I think that a one.
I think that the ICU not needed to sort
fact from fiction at the moment is
enormous.
The amount of money you'd need would be.
Oh yeah,
right.
Fantastic.
Actually today with Hashtag fake news.
So I am,
um,
I'm sort of feeling like I'm witnessing
the battle for whether any authority
exists at all and the claim that you
fact check has been synonymized with the
fact that you're truthful,
which is total nonsense.
In other words,
if I accurately represent three people
who were in a,
in a scene and I,
and I leave out to others and somebody
says that fact you know,
that that picture is fake.
I said,
no,
no.
These three people really were there.
Yes,
but you filtered out those other things,
you know,
you can tell lies by leaving things out
by insinuation.
Uh,
I have this whole riff on,
um,
what I,
uh,
frequently refer to as Russell
conjugation that other people call it
motive conjugation.
So,
you know,
the difference between fink versus
whistle blower is how I usually
introduce this.
You have,
these are technically synonyms in
English,
but you cannot substitute one for the
other.
Whistleblower don't.
Well with whistleblowers,
the only is usually one of the only
positive ones.
Chelsea manning is a highly regarded
rat,
can't.
It doesn't work because of the emotional
shading.
Like another thing is to get somebody
proximate to something very disturbing.
So Ben Shapiro and I were in this
article about how the alt right was
outraged and we were like the two people
cited neither supposed to be outright
you,
right?
Jesus Christ.
Alright thing is a weird thing to know.
It's a great game.
You have to appreciate what it is.
Okay?
So if you're trying to silence the very
small number of people who are probably
your guests [inaudible] I'm the right
thing to do is to make sure that their
proximate to lots of terrible stuff so
that people who are too busy to sort
things out so well,
you know,
I neither condemned nor condone because
all you're trying to do is to muddle
everything.
You need enough fear,
uncertainty and doubt in order to get
the job done.
And so it doesn't matter that the
article says,
you know,
in the banner headline outright enraged,
and then the two people you know,
listed are like Jews who opposed trump.
But because when,
when those articles are parsed,
um,
it shows up as while
you were in a bunch of articles about
the outright.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I get it.
You're really not paying attention and
uh,
the,
the point isn't to inform the reader.
The point is to tag that which you wish
to neutralize.
And so it's working very well.
Do people in the alt right consider
themselves outright,
um,
or did they use to when it's become sort
of a pejorative?
So,
so,
so let's go through the craziness here.
Assume that you are not a democrat.
I'm not a Democrat,
might translate to libertarian.
The more Republicans,
Republican translates to right of
center,
right?
Of Center,
translates to right wing,
translates to far,
right,
translates to outright translates to
white supremacist,
translates to Neo Nazi,
translates to Nazi,
right?
And so you have these very strange
chains on the left were Republican,
keeps bleeding into Nazi,
right?
Because of this very weird thing.
It's like,
well,
you said,
you said you didn't vote Democrat.
So I.
Can I say that you're right wing.
I mean your far right,
right.
You're,
you're basically outright,
she's holy crap,
you just,
you know,
moved somebody who's a country club
Republican into being a Capo,
a agent,
you know,
and does not necessarily mean white
supremacists are the,
they conveniently glued those two things
together.
I think Richard Spencer,
um,
considers himself all right.
Well,
I think he coined outright so,
you know,
the ideas,
white supremacy with a human face and a
human faces as opposed to wildland a
goat.
No,
he was trying,
he was trying to change the,
it was trying to come up with a
friendlier version of Nazi or a white
supremacist Solaris.
Right?
And so at some level that was a
disgusting intellectual master stroke,
but then alright,
became the play thing.
Um,
you know,
a lot of people who are tired of being
told what to think and who to be started
blurring these distinctions.
So now you've got this frog and
sometimes you put a hat on the frog,
sometimes it's the Nazi hat,
sometimes the trump hat.
Right?
And so the whole idea is like,
okay,
um,
for those of us who got used to those
lines that we do not cross,
those were major transgressions to other
people.
They're like,
well why should there be a rule about a
frog?
Right.
And so you have this crazy discussion
where you have people with terrible
insidious intent,
people who are just clowning around and
everybody is mixed in in a way that
nobody can sort out.
Right?
Like the frog.
That's Keck,
right?
Yeah.
I mean if you really pay attention and I
think there's been some sort of a study
done on what percentage of the frog is
actually used for,
you know,
Donald trump or racism or outright.
And what percentage of the frog is used
just for goof.
It's the vast majority is like feels
good man type things.
But like maybe seen,
I get sent to many Nazi frogs during the
election.
I've been sent a few,
right?
Like anybody could make one make a Nazi
and people have made this mickey mouse.
But you know,
we didn't use to like there's still a
lot of stigma around reproducing
swastikas with the color scheme and the
orientation of the Third Reich to have
you seen that the gay folks,
for what?
For a very short period of time,
we're trying to co op the swastika and
turned into a rainbow swastika.
Take it back.
Oh my gosh.
Well,
when you go to India,
right?
You have the swastikas,
you know,
pointing the other direction with dots
in them.
And so if you come from an American
context,
you're just fucking triggered all this
place up here.
There's a place in Chatsworth,
I believe,
that is in a very,
very old Indian temple that has
swastikas on it.
And there's a large sign but it's not.
It's reverse swastika is a large sign
explaining,
you know,
hey,
this is an ancient Hindu symbol and
we've had it for a long time and longer.
Right?
I mean,
my guess I haven't looked at the,
at the etymology,
but I would guess that swag comes from
beautiful in Sanskrit or something.
And so,
you know,
the question about who does assemble
belong to and when is an inexorable and
when is it an extra bowl,
when is it a,
like that symmetry pattern.
I have no question that you might find
that symmetry pattern in nature or you
know,
in like ninth century Islamic art
architecture or something.
Well,
you know,
the hexagon they found on top of
Jupiter,
remember that the storm,
you know,
what,
if it was a swastika,
could you imagine instead of a hexagon,
there's a swastika on top of Jupiter.
Jesus Christ you think is really take at
Jupiter was a Saturday.
Was it Saturday?
Jupiter might've been saturn there,
but there was some very bizarre pattern
pattern.
That's a very strange.
Yeah.
But it.
And it's uniform.
I mean it's like pretty close to an
actual hexagon.
I believe so yeah,
it,
it is very weird that we get so wrapped
up in symbols and symbols are so huge
for us.
But they are efficient compressions and
information.
So you know,
and then you lose,
you know,
assemble like you can lose the name.
I'm like,
Dick,
nobody's calling a kid's Dick was gay,
right?
Get it used to be gay old time.
The flintstones,
they had a gay old time.
That was one of the last uses of gay in
that my grandfather claimed that the
emotion of gaiety was lost with the
word.
He claimed that there was actually an
emotion that went with it,
but no one actually experiences anymore.
Wow.
Um,
but how does he describe it?
That it was a sort of a careless
frivolity
that had,
had a certain,
sort of a combination of like innocence
tinge with a little bit of a mischief
like sexual mischief really.
Anyway,
you know,
so we become aware of words that opened
up new territory.
So like the concept of Synack,
uh,
in Thai and lots of people go through
Thailand come back and they need the
words and look,
which is the quality of fun that
something has to have in order for it to
be worth doing.
Like,
did you pay your electrical bill?
Know why there was no snuck in it,
you know,
so that,
that was like,
that's a concept or Chutzpah,
you know,
coming from Yiddish or Turkish has Yakka
Mo's,
which is the trail of light left on the
water by the moon.
Right?
And so once you have a word for Yakima
was,
it's very hard not to use it even though
nobody in English speaking context knows
about it.
Just the way the word Selfie,
uh,
if you recall when that came in,
we'd seen all these weird pictures of
like ladies and you know,
uh,
restrooms taking pictures of themselves
in the mirror and you're like,
what the hell is that?
Somebody says,
oh,
that's a selfie.
And I was like,
got it.
Right.
And then suddenly that word was
everywhere.
So once we get the symbolic compression
that goes with a concept,
we become pretty dangerous.
My wife has a friend and so stupid,
she has no one a selfie means.
So she takes,
she uses Hashtag selfie and somebody
else takes the picture.
Yeah.
The nature of her,
she doesn't have a fucking camera in her
hand and she's standing there with their
hands on her hips.
I would love to joke with you.
I have definitely used that Hashtag
selfie.
I've thought Selfie when it's not a
Selfie at all.
Well,
I mean it was just her picture of
herself.
Maybe she set up the camera.
Maybe I'm the Asshole,
right?
Isn't it?
Is it a selfie?
If you put a timer on a camera and he
stepped back and will fuck me.
I'm an asshole.
He's a talmudic questions of our right.
I'm wrong.
Maybe she's got a.
maybe if you just have a husband that's
so dominant,
just sit around and take pictures of you
so you can put them on instagram.
I mean,
you,
you basically programmed itself.
You have a program monkey that'll take
pictures.
It's extend itself.
Exactly.
Yeah.
If you,
uh,
if you shoot a pheasant and you have a
dog that will fetch that bird and bring
it back to you,
you still shot the bird a pheasant?
Yeah.
Do you know how they do that?
You,
you flushed the birds out with dogs,
the birds go up in the air,
they shoot them out with a shotgun,
the birds hit the ground,
the dog gets it and brings it back to
you.
But you shot it.
Yeah.
That's why they only call them
retrievers and things.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
But we're learning a lot of shit.
Let's,
let's just go over all we covered.
No,
no quiz,
but we recovered why we're moving
because there's a fucking earthquake
going on on the roof.
Um,
Indian music,
a cephalopods sneaker males,
sneaker sneaker males.
Yeah.
I didn't know so many things I didn't
know about.
It's not like a common thing though,
like everybody kind of knows that's what
a lot of male feminists are there.
Like,
like sneaker males,
they like sliding in closer proximity to
the females by,
you know,
by trying to sort of as pals some ideals
that they think would be more attractive
to the females because they don't find
them in nature.
Yeah.
And then the problem is that the
ambulatory window comes along and
suddenly there's a desire for something
completely different and they go out
with some biker right?
Immediately it was like,
what happened with that?
It's like,
I don't know.
It was strangely appealing.
Yeah,
it's that fucking gene poll,
man,
the Goddamn genetics they've got us put.
It is really amazing how we're conscious
and we're,
we're aware of all these issues that we
deal with,
but yet we're still,
we're still at the firm to a certain
extent at the whim of these genes,
of these,
these poles that we have inside of us.
That's like the argument that people
always make for why some people find
like subsistence living,
like those shows in Alaska.
So oddly comforting you ever see those
shows is you're really close with the
environment that brought you here.
Yeah.
Like Alaska,
the final frontier.
You see that show notes,
folks just live up in there.
They're actually related to that woman
jewel.
Do you know that beautiful singer jewel?
Remember some amazing voice and uh,
she is related to those folks that live
in Alaska and they have this show where
they live mean they live way the fuck up
there with nobody around them.
They are literally in just bumfuck
nowhere,
Alaska to do that.
But it's oddly comforting.
I'd love those shows.
I don't know why I love those shows.
What really do I think you might.
I could see you doing that,
delivered like that.
Nah.
Nah,
I'd like to do it in little bursts.
Yeah.
I enjoy a movie theater,
sir.
I like a highway.
I like to drive cars.
I,
uh,
I enjoy television.
I like cooking in a home.
I liked doing that.
I like sitting down with electricity.
I like all the trappings of
civilization,
but I do enjoy going to nature.
I have no desire to be a trapper and
fucking,
you know,
flying around in a Bush plane,
landing places and checking my steel
traps for minx and stuff.
Yeah.
Those are the folks.
Is that her in there?
Obviously.
Super Old picture of it.
Is she one of them?
Is she the girl with the red sweater?
Yeah,
probably I forget the name of the family
killed.
Killed.
Sure.
Yeah,
I think that is it.
but I mean these fucking people,
they make their own houses up there.
I like that.
And somehow or another she escaped.
She probably lives in Venice now.
Some shit.
My Arch Nemesis is this guy,
Garrett Lee see lives in Maui.
Oh yeah.
Why you guys?
Arch Nemesis is you don't have one.
Uh,
I don't think so.
You should totally get one.
What are they good for you?
Well,
first of all,
lots of billionaires for cotton to have
an arch nemesis.
You go to movies about arch nemeses.
I don't know what the plural is,
but it's like,
it's definitely one of these things
almost nobody has.
And your arch nemesis has to be somewhat
like you.
So you know,
like there is tension that there should
only be one.
Oh yeah.
See,
I'm not an,
there should only be one guy.
I'm a tribal guy.
I think you should gather up as many
people that are like you and support
each other.
Well,
you do end up supporting your economics
that you keep each other going.
Oh right.
And it's some sort of a way,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
I mean definitely.
We definitely need some sort of
competition.
I definitely believe that.
So my,
my arch nemesis took me out into the
jungles of northern Mali.
Kill you.
I thought so really?
We wonder if you have an enemy.
And he says,
Hey man,
you want to go hiking?
Like,
fuck bro.
Well,
I was,
I was down for it because I just
thought,
look,
I'm not sure that he's the one is coming
back.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Anyway,
we're on this trail and um,
we're visiting this phd mathematician in
the jungles.
It is without question the most mosquito
ridden place I've ever been.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's unlivable now.
He has some incredible rainforest.
Incredible.
And we get out along this trail hike
like a mile or two in and this guy has
built Shangrila.
He's taken this river and he's,
you know,
he's been there for like 25,
30,
40 years and he's,
he's like a phd in differential
geometry.
Wow.
He like lives into this amazing jury in
tree fruit Durian.
Is that.
Yeah,
that's that stinky fruit.
Right.
Why would he do that?
Because if you've ever had great,
and it's one of the great pleasures of
life really?
Oh God.
So it stinks,
but it tastes good.
Yeah.
It's like limburger cheese.
Oh,
okay.
That's a good analysis.
So anyway,
this guy has built this solitary world
that nobody is watching,
like it's a performance for one and it's
like this naturally sculpted wonderland
that he lives in with all these
mosquitoes that he doesn't notice under
his diary entries where you can do
mathematics.
Why does he not notice him?
Has.
Because you've been there for 30.
Yeah.
Wow.
I mean you can't.
You can't focus on that for 30 years.
He needs to get one of those.
A thermo sells.
You ever seen those things?
Oh,
they're amazing.
Yeah.
If you go to anywhere where the
mosquitoes are particularly aggressive
because like if you go to a Alaska,
if you've been to Alaska before,
sir,
one thing about Alaska that's fantastic
is the mosquitoes are fucking rabid.
They are like pit polls.
Me and my friend Ari went fishing in
Alaska and I am not exaggerating.
No,
we didn't.
We,
we spread ourselves up with fucking
horrible chemicals that probably took a
year off my life,
but when you step out of the car,
I
mean when we opened up,
look at that,
that's like legitimately what it's like.
We opened up the door to the car and
within three to five seconds there was
100 mosquitoes inside the car.
It's fucking insane because they're only
alive for like a month,
right?
It's only warm enough for them to exist
for a short period of time,
so they're insanely aggressive.
So anyway,
there's this product called thermacell
that outdoors people use and what it is
is it's like a small pad that looks like
a large square,
like piece of gum or something like
that,
and you slide this blue pad under this
screen and then you ignite it by
pressing a button.
This little heating element goes off and
it has like a little fuel canister that
keeps this very tiny fire.
It's immensely small.
You have to look into see if it's lit
right.
It's probably not even a fire.
It's like somehow or another element is
heating up this fuel.
It takes a long time to go through a
small canister,
but it emits this very fine mist and
this missed.
We'll keep a like an 18 square foot,
get out window of protection from Ms
Dot.
Dude.
It is impossible to be in the outdoors
with it without it rather once you've
had it.
It's,
I,
I've found out about it from a,
um,
my friends in Alberta,
they,
uh,
they were,
the first turned me on about it.
They live in Alberta and the same thing
in Alberta that mosquitoes are super,
super aggressive because it's only warm
enough for them to exist for short
period of time.
I'm so glad I did the show.
Dude.
Thermacell is amazing and you can strap
them to your hip.
You just put one on right there and you
don't even smell it.
And the mosquitoes don't want to have
nothing to do with it.
They just keep them.
They try some,
like really aggressive ones.
Go,
you motherfucker.
I'm gonna give up.
I mean,
it's amazing.
It makes a,
being in the woods incredibly bearable.
Like a meet.
My daughters wanted to go camping in the
back yard one night.
There was bugs out there and I said,
Oh,
I've got the solution now.
When I got my thermacell,
let that sucker put it there.
Everybody's a alcohol sleeping.
Just no problems at all.
Bugs and civilians can purchase this.
Yeah,
well it's not.
It's not toxic,
but it's super easy to use.
That's it right there.
Yeah,
so that.
Thanks to that blue thing in the top.
That's a piece of the thermacell,
the chewing gum looking stuff.
These slide under that screen and when
it gets used up,
that blue thing becomes all white.
It's so easy to use mat.
Go to like,
come check it.
Just to say that they have a large one
there that looks like a lamp.
See that one?
That looks like a lamp up there.
Fucking dude.
Those things are the shit.
I hate mosquitoes.
Oh thermacell.
So way to go.
I mean I don't look google the negative
consequences.
You see that?
See that one?
He's got like pouches on the side of the
container and one pound she would have
like your little extra fuel canisters
and the other side.
You'd probably have some of those little
extra thermacell paths,
but one little thing,
one of those little blue things last for
like eight hours.
So I mean one of the great questions is
some of the most beautiful land,
uh,
in a place like Maui is mosquito ridden.
And so if some,
if that worked,
could you change the land value?
You'd have to burn them all the time and
I don't know if it's something you want
to breathe in all the time and I just
don't,
I don't know enough about negative
consequences but I've used them a bunch
of times and they've never even given me
a headache or anything.
Find out if whatever's in thermacell is
like safe for long term exposure is
you're not supposed to use in a confined
space.
Oh,
okay.
Because there is some sort of stuff
you're obviously breathing in for sure,
but permanent permit then than parent
within.
I don't know how come.
Nothing.
You know,
I've asked this before,
but when we were kids and you read comic
books,
but like radiation,
they always helped people turn people
into fucking superheroes.
Yeah.
You never hear that shit in real life.
You have to get lucky and get some hobby
attic mutations.
So you've got like straight arms coming
out of your head and never does anything
good.
No,
no mutations in bugs.
They're really cool.
Well,
yeah,
and bugs that I mean in,
in human beings like I mean I guess or
the Chinese experimented with that
probably.
That was the thing about crispr that I
was going to bring up earlier for sure.
They're doing that right?
They're making humans.
Yeah,
I mean that's the thing about like
having this ethical moral stance on the
use of something like crisper to
genetically alter fetus that if you do
that,
you've really.
If,
if you have an opposition to altering
embryos,
that's immoral.
It's not something we want to be a part
of.
Yeah,
but that's the problem.
They already passed that.
The Russians don't give a fuck about
that.
Did you see that movie?
I'm a ICARUS.
No,
God damn.
You have to see that movie,
right sir?
Um,
I had Bryan Fogel on last week who is
the director and producer of this
documentary on the doping,
the Russian state sponsored doping
program.
Russians don't play dude.
They don't play.
They had a state sponsored doping
program that was kind of overseen by,
by Putin,
like down the line,
like there's a direct chain of command
and the whole entire Russian team is so
cheap was on drugs.
All of them.
The Guy who engineered the whole thing,
like the main scientist is in the United
States now under protective custody in
hiding.
And Putin is trying to drag them back to
Russia by stealing the homes from his
family,
stealing his wives home,
turned him into homeless people in some
sort of a lure to get him to sacrifice
himself to come back for the health and
safety of his family.
Do you remember what happened when?
Sit down that it didn't work out so
good.
The cell phone video,
that's when you know you fucked up cell
phone.
Video footage of your execution.
Oh,
that's that.
Saddam's execution.
But I think he learned his son and his
son in laws back,
like,
don't worry,
it's all forgiven than the southern
Illinois came back and then.
Oh really?
It was the,
it was pretty skilled in,
uh,
in.
Oh,
this
was a different situation then I
thought,
no,
no.
The self.
I mean,
even though that was a very strange
situation because he actually was the
only guy was like,
he had his shit together when he was
being executed.
He understood the game.
He accepted the gap.
So I got it right.
But also he's probably like,
Jesus Christ.
How many people did I kill?
I got the,
I think after you've killed like a few
hundred thousand people,
you probably like,
I probably deserve it.
Yeah.
I'm,
well,
I know you've ever seen a Christopher
hitchens.
I'm narrating the original bath party.
Um,
don't know.
I don't know what to call it.
Theatrical video where like half the
bath party was called out as being
revealed traders.
And then the other half of the bath
party was giving,
given side arms with which to execute
them,
making them complicit in the founding
murder.
And there was all filmed,
oh,
I'm aware of this,
but I didn't know that Christopher
hitchens narrated it.
Well,
he did something where he,
he brought it to prominence,
right?
I think I was aware of it with just
Arabic and I couldn't tell what was
going on.
And then he actually said,
okay,
look,
you have to appreciate.
Well,
this is a topic that I think would be
good to talk about.
I don't know that I've ever talked about
it,
but message violence is the glue that
keeps a lot of societies together and we
don't study it or talk about violence
that is specifically constructed to be
theatrical.
I'm like public beheadings.
Yeah.
Um,
that would be it kind of message
violence,
um,
or for example,
forcing families to pay for the
ammunition with which their family
members were executed to make them
complicit and emphasize their weakness.
Um,
all of the stuff that the mind goes to
horror movies to explore,
uh,
is often used structurally,
particularly in the Middle East.
Um,
so,
you know,
Isis,
for example,
the Jordanian pilot video,
which I find that many people haven't
seen,
the whole point of it was that the
pilots were raining down,
death into particular forms,
rubble and fire when people in the
ground and isis captured one of the
Jordanian pilots and decided that they
would theatrically execute him with a
version of exactly these two things,
um,
that he was meeting out from the air.
And so the whole point of it was to
create the cinematic imagery,
um,
to sear into people's mind what it meant
to oppose isis that isis was in fact
just in a sort of eye for an eye kind of
way.
And,
um,
you know,
my belief is,
is that we don't understand
the role that message violence plays in
part because we are now denying it.
If you think about Vietnam,
we have all of these images that were
burned into all of our minds.
I'm with Pulitzer Prize winning
photographs.
But in the modern era,
you don't have images like that from
Iraq because there was a,
there was a decision that we could not
afford in some sense,
to have the kind of opposition that we
had to Vietnam when people suddenly
said,
wait,
wait a minute,
you're doing what in my name.
There's a,
there's an issue that has always puzzled
me.
And this issue is people that lean left,
people that consider themselves
progressives have a very distinct,
very obvious bias against criticizing
Islam,
criticizing Islamic terrorism,
criticizing a Islamic suppression of
women.
You know,
that these criticizing these cultures,
uh,
under the guise of not wanting to
promote Islamophobia and things on those
lines.
And I've always wondered how much of
what that is,
is a fear of reprisal,
of speaking out against them is
terrifying.
So what they do instead is embraced the
cultural differences that these people
exhibit concentrate instead on the
positive aspects of their community.
And the good things about Muslim culture
and Islamic culture and not really does
not bring it up at all.
Like you very rarely hear people on the
left talk about how oppressive and
horrific some of the conditions that
women and homosexuals are forced to live
in,
in Muslim cultures.
Right.
And I've always wondered if that's what
that is.
Like there's a fee because no one in
modern day and no one ideology is more
brutal in there reprisal.
I mean they kill apostates,
right?
They killed people who leave.
If you join,
you can join.
No one's stopping them.
They're all.
The whole idea of spreading Islam is
that you should be proselytizing.
You should be getting people to join
because it is the only truth is the only
way to go.
But once you do join the urine like you,
you're not allowed to leave.
First of all,
let's actually do this one.
I think it's important,
but they didn't start that.
We Jews started this so far as I know.
So if you go.
No,
no,
no.
We don't.
We don't proselytize,
but the.
Once you're in,
you're in a really?
Yeah.
If you go to deuteronomy,
I think it says something to the effect
of if someone comes to you and says,
Hey,
let's worship God's not known to the
father's a set upon them with the stone
before anyone else gets there,
but are you supposed to do that to
someone who is already converted to?
If you're in,
if you're in,
you're in and somebody says,
Hey,
let's go worship other gods.
You're supposed to kill them,
but what if that was so interesting?
Like,
so it's
an old idea.
It's an old idea and it's not an Islamic
idea.
It's a Jewish idea in my opinion.
Okay.
But it does exist today,
primarily.
So I asked my rabbi about this and she
did.
She said,
you have a female rabbi,
you progressive motherfucker,
you will look at,
you know,
I have.
I actually,
I like it.
I'm proud of this.
I have a rabbi who happens to be female
born female or was it one of them?
She's all woman.
All rabbi allegedly.
They're all women.
Caitlyn Jenner's all incendiary topics.
Do you want.
No,
no,
no.
Let's just turn everything up to 11.
Come on,
man.
I'm a comedian,
right?
Have a boss in three minutes.
I'm about to be a target.
Oh,
okay.
You're a no targeting female rabbi.
So her point was,
yeah.
And we don't execute anybody.
Um,
because in ineffective,
that portion of the code never runs.
So the Jews have figured out how to have
bad code that is almost permanently
inoperative.
Hmm.
If I could stop you there for a second.
One of the unique things about Jews is
that there are so many Jewish people
that I know that it's still considered
themselves Jewish but are almost totally
atheist.
Yeah.
Like my friend Ari,
like he was doing this video recently
where this podcast recently and was,
we were doing this challenge where we
can't drink or smoke pot or do anything
for a month and we have to do 15 hot
yoga classes and he's going crazy and
screaming during his podcast.
I am a Jewish performer and I live in
New York City.
I'm supposed to be doing drugs.
I was supposed to be drinking.
I liked drinking.
Um,
but he's,
he's the biggest atheist I've ever met
in my life,
or if not an atheist,
he certainly at the very least agnostic
at the very least.
He's definitely not as someone who
considers himself a religious person,
but he was,
yeah,
he wasn't.
He escaped the clause of it when he was
young.
But it's Jews many times think of
himself,
it's almost a tribe as much as it is a
religion.
Like if you,
you sit down and corner.
Most Jews that I know about,
like how much of the Talmud do you
follow?
How much?
How much of the Old Testament do you
think is legit?
How much of the,
the,
these,
these teachings do you think are
imperative for everyday living is.
It was the vast majority don't want to
have they,
they're not connected to any of it.
If you're following the Old Testament,
you wouldn't recognize him as a Jew.
Right?
Right.
We have to kill the apostates.
I used to live in an ultra Orthodox
neighborhood in Jerusalem and at some
point I was writing on the Sabbath,
my final list for leaving and the kids
in the building next door started
shouting in Hebrew.
It is forbidden to write on the Sabbath,
kill him.
Whoa.
And the parents had to kind of knock it
off like the ultra orthodox parents.
So they wanted to kill you because you
were writing because it was
literally that,
that was,
I was violated on a bunch of little
monsters.
Now moms are,
is the word you're looking bastards.
Anyway.
Yeah.
So Jews are big into observance,
but part of the relationship is you get
to question things that are much deeper
level than in most religions.
And you know,
I would say six or seven rabbis well
enough to ask the question about their
belief structure.
None of them believe in the character of
God from the Old Testament.
So how do they sort of rationalized the
whole thing?
Well,
that's the whole point is you have
layers of abstraction and um,
you know,
if you're really stupid,
for example,
do you believe that the supreme court is
a nine black robed a super geniuses who
can channel the original intent of the
founding fathers?
I think they're wizards.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just like wizard.
Well then then that sounds it.
I mean,
you,
there's a grownup way of loving your
country and there's a childish way of
loving your country and there's a
grownup way of believing in your
religion and the childish childish one
is like,
yeah,
it's all literally.
But what is the grown up way of
believing in a religion?
Well,
I mean,
in part,
and it's got a lot of hidden
instructions.
It's,
it's not resolved so that you have these
sort of dialectical tensions that a sea
of like ethical guidelines as opposed to
like,
yeah,
that's not telling you exactly what,
down from on high and giant stone
tablets,
well,
you know,
thou shalt not kill,
thou shalt not kill has to go up against
an admission to kill.
Right.
And so these things are not resolved in
there,
but I'm trying to swim back upstream to
your original point about Islam.
We're going to get waylaid here.
Will you leave Israel or Jews
particularly?
There is an answer to this and I used to
know it,
but I forgot it.
What is the reason why so many European
Jews have won Nobel prizes?
So many European Jews are insanely
intelligent.
Like what is the modern social justice
answer?
It's because we cheated physics.
Want you that answer?
That's a joke.
That's a silly answer.
No,
no,
no.
They're fucking smart.
Like why?
Why are so many insanely intelligent
people?
European Jews.
So you.
Is it hard for you to answer being a
Jew?
Yeah.
A little bit.
Like if you asked me about,
uh,
well let,
let,
let's do a different one.
Okay.
So from 18,
97 and 1987,
you had all of these different countries
winning the Boston marathon.
Then from 1987 to the president
basically to Kenya and Ethiopia,
maybe a Korean guy wins it or something.
Why is that?
Well,
now you have this really uncomfortable
thing which is,
uh,
is it culture?
Is it that those guys in east Africa
just have heart?
Is it because they really run to,
to school everyday?
Twenty six miles.
People said that and then turns out they
take the bus like everybody else.
So there can be a genetic predisposition
in tradeoffs space.
There can be a cultural premium.
So,
uh,
when you have the top marriage
prospects,
do you marry them off to the,
to the richest or the smartest?
So in Judaism there is some weird way in
which intellectual prestige proxies for,
um,
material wealth.
So if you have somebody who's insanely
smart,
not very rich,
it can be very prestigious to marry
your,
uh,
your daughter,
let's say to that a student of the tour.
So there are all sorts of cultural
strange aspects of this.
Is it because money lending was
prescribed and forbidden to Christians
that this particular facility with
mathematics was highly selected for when
nobody else was selecting for it?
You know,
I don't know what the answer is,
but I do know that I'm like,
in my case,
getting a phd in mathematics using an
Ivy league education for that,
or in my brother's case,
giving up an ivy league education to
make a point.
I'm standing up for social justice.
These are sort of self destructive
things in most cultures.
Standing up for social justice against
social justice warriors.
We,
in his case,
he stood up because a Jewish fraternity
was using black strippers for sexual
entertainment to a lure in a incoming
freshman.
And he said,
okay,
this is,
you know,
this is some sort of class oriented
thing where we're exploiting one.
This is a different situation.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
So he had,
he had to leave Penn,
university of Pennsylvania under death
threats.
Um,
wow.
So,
you know,
this is the great irony of my brother's
situation is that for people who don't
know who your brother,
Bret Weinstein,
yeah.
Is a Weinstein.
Harvey Weinstein.
Bret Weinstein,
right?
I'm Brett,
was the guy that was the part of the
whole Evergreen college fiasco.
He's been on this podcast twice.
I suggest if you're interested,
you could either google his name and get
the story from a multitude of sources or
listen to the original podcast where he
sort of laid it out.
It was before the settlement with the
college before he wound up leaving and
you know,
I really hope that he goes the Jordan
Peterson route,
meaning that he starts putting up these
lectures and some of these ideas that he
has just putting them up on online.
It just putting videos up and patriot.
I know he's got a patriot on page now,
correct?
Yep.
And that.
Which is a great way to do it too.
But
Jordan is making more money from doing
that than he ever did.
From College.
Yeah.
For Teaching University.
I want to support.
You know,
the other thing is,
is that we have to make the case because
he can't because it'll look wrong.
Right.
Hire this motherfucker that
motherfucker.
Yeah.
I mean he's amazing.
He's a straight up genius.
I have a recommendation for him from his
old advisor who I think he said he's the
top student in 40 years of advising and
just we have to recognize that if you
want this stuff to stop,
you have to make it not pay to drive
super smart people who are courageous
enough to be open in their thinking and
just shared.
I'm sorry.
Keep going.
Yeah.
Um,
and to share and to share their
thoughts.
And fundamentally,
if we drive these people to extinction,
it's on us.
And so my question is,
hey,
University of Chicago,
Harvard,
Princeton,
Stanford,
where are you?
Yeah.
I mean,
some people are terrified of
repercussions,
but they think that he's a.
he's a guy from evergreen state,
so he's lower rank.
Let me,
let me use my tiny megaphone to say he's
not lower rank.
He's unfucking believably smart.
Look at his work on Elongate of
telomeres in laboratory animals where he
predicted what Nobel laureate Carol
Greider found from first principles that
the mice that are being used to test our
drugs have wildly exaggerated telomere
lengths.
Giving them amazing capacities for
histological repair,
but pop possibly putting drugs to market
that shouldn't be there.
This is somebody you want to be taking
intellectually serious and stop treating
this like the clown act that they're
running and this just happens to be a
victim.
Well,
Evergreen college is an amazing example
of what can go wrong if you let these
crazy children sort of dictate the way
human beings are allowed to behave and
the way discourse takes place on campus
to the cliff notes what I was going to
say,
they wanted to have a day of absence.
They've added traditionally had a day of
absence where people of color would take
the day off to school for where people
would miss them.
Sort of like,
didn't they engineer that in La,
David Without Mexicans who was a movie,
right?
It would shut down.
We'll just tell you right now.
LS shuts down without Mexicans,
but too,
but instead of doing that,
the social justice warrior mentality
that thinks that every white man is some
sort of an oppressor and you need to
figure out a way to eradicate them from
the world.
They decided to go the opposite route
and force white staff and white students
to stay home.
Your brother rightly protested saying
that is inherently racist.
Like what you're proposing is is an anti
racist?
Yes,
he's anti.
The problem is that the diversity
movement which has now become the equity
movement,
is actually racist,
racist against white people.
It's,
I mean,
I don't even want to say it's reverse
racism and racism against white.
It's openly racist.
Reverse either racism or not racism.
That whole proposal,
that racism against white people is
reverse race.
Now this is a cult and the way you know
that it's a cult is you ask for the
definition of racism and if somebody
tells you it's power plus prejudice and
therefore certain groups can't be racist
because they have no power.
That's how you know somebody in the cult
because if you look it up in the
dictionary,
it doesn't say anything like that.
Another one would be a gender has
nothing to do with sex.
Go to the Oxford English dictionary.
Look at the difference between three
versus three.
Be a gender and sex have been closely
tied and sometime like in the 19
forties,
a couple of fields in the US started
using gender to be behavior sex to be
that which is your dedicated genotype
phenotype.
What what is going on is is that these
people are changing the definition of
words in order to push a cult into the
exact place where it must not go.
It must not go in the diversity office.
It must not go in hr.
You cannot have this openly racist,
openly sexist cult in the place where
the which is the immune system,
and so that's.
That's.
That's the key thing is that we're used
to thinking of our immune system is
being there to protect us,
but if you think about an auto immune
disease,
it's when your immune system starts
attacking the self that you're in real
trouble.
So learn the signs and learn the tells.
You don't have to sign up for Jordan
Peterson's postmodernism.
Just ask somebody whether black people
can be racist against whites and as soon
as you hear power plus prejudice,
you know you're talking to a cult
member.
As soon as you hear the gender and sex
have nothing to do with each other,
right?
And you have recourse to dictionaries
and you start talking about the history
and somebody starts,
well,
that's your white fragility.
That's your white privilege.
Why are you in denial?
Why aren't you accepting allyship?
So suddenly it's like,
okay,
it's Xenu in the volcanoes and the
clams.
Again,
it is.
Yeah,
And um,
well one,
one great piece of evidence about that
was this whole google memo thing,
that Google memo thing,
the difference between what that guy
actually wrote on the memo and what was
published in so many different
publications.
So many different online websites.
It's just straight up libelous like that
guy,
if I mean I know he's going to sue
google,
but he's.
He could probably sue a host of people
once he's done with that because they
changed what he wrote and turned him
into this horrible evil,
sexist person to the point where the CEO
of Google have a youtube rather was
saying that she.
She read it and it made her sad at the
whole thing,
made her sad.
Well,
he wrote up a piece based on why people
of different genders are more inclined
to gravitate toward specific things.
You made an error how,
what was the error?
The error that he made was,
is that he used a reserved term
neuroticism,
the big five personality inventory where
it is a reserved term denoting a
particular psychometric and so rather
than saying men are less conscientious
than women,
women are more neurotic,
women are more neurotic.
I actually brought that up with him and
he regretted it.
He regretted bringing that because I
told them.
I said that's my only criticism is like
that's a derogatory term,
but again,
I'm not quite remembered that the big
five personality inventory,
you know,
his openness,
conscientiousness,
extroversion,
agreeableness,
and neuroticism.
But you know,
when you see something that careful,
I mean most people just didn't read it.
They went with the headline.
So that's the first thing you should
guess somebody that's smart is probably
using a term,
if I say moral hazard to you and you
don't know economics,
you're going to think,
oh wow,
what is the moral hazard?
Is that like reefer has nothing to do
with that.
It's a reserved term,
right?
So if I keep talking about rent seeking
or moral hazard,
and I'm talking about landlords,
you know,
or somebody offering your kid a Doobie
afterschool,
right,
right.
So,
so that was like the first intellectual
failure.
I and I,
I just have been dealing with this with
or I talk about power laws and
statistics,
which is a particular type of
probability distribution.
And somebody says,
Geez,
the power powerful people in our country
are so protected and privileged.
Why are we,
why do we need laws to protect them?
Like what?
Oh,
you said power law.
It's like that has nothing to do with
the.
There used to be this character on
Saturday night live,
whose name was emily Latella,
played by Gilda radner and they bring
her in and she was hard of hearing.
Say,
what's this?
I hear about a death penalty.
The death have problems enough as it is,
and then she'd riff for two minutes and
the death penalty.
It's like,
oh,
that's entirely different.
Nevermind.
So she was trying to remember like
violins on television.
Can you read classical music?
Kitchen random was awesome.
She was awesome.
Zana,
Rosanna Danna.
Oh my God.
You couldn't do any of this stuff
anymore.
You couldn't.
You really couldn't.
But I'm getting back to the demore
thing.
I'm just checking our tree and it's
exploding here.
You know the thing about what he did was
he was trying to write a pro diversity
memo.
If you lie about the differences between
men and women,
what are your odds that you will be able
to hack a solution to get getting all
the brilliant women?
In our country who care about stem into
the workforce,
this is what we need to do.
There's no shortage of brilliant women
know I've collaborated with them.
I know they're there.
We need to figure out as a society do we
need to pay women more so that we can
get them out of working in the home and
taking care of older parents and young
children during their prime years.
We need to be very creative about the
actual differences between men and
women.
Should we have a rule not equal pay for
equal work,
but equal pay for unequal salary
negotiation if we don't allow ourselves,
but please,
please elaborate on that because that is
an issue with why women sometimes make
less than men,
is that they don't have the same sort of
aggressive salary negotiating tendencies
that a lot of men do.
Aggressive testosterone driven,
sort of.
I mean,
there's all sorts of things.
You know,
again,
I don't want to mansplain any.
That's not a big issue too.
I mean,
look at Chekhov.
Short story called the Nincompoop in
which an employer and a domestic worker
in his home and he talks to her about
all of her wages and then he starts
taking away little bit by little bit
for,
you know,
you broke a cup and you were a little
bit late and he whittles her
compensation down to nothing and she
accepts it.
And then he says,
the employer says,
you,
you stupid fool.
I've just cheated you out of your entire
wages.
I'm going to give them to you,
but understand that this is how an
employer cheats and employee and you're
just like,
whoa.
So this is,
uh,
an old Russian speaking a truth,
which is don't allow yourself to get
taken advantage of.
Now you could say that's really horrible
because it's called the Nincompoop,
right?
Or You could say,
actually that was an attempt to talk
about a problem about needing to be more
aggressive and more assertive.
So getting back to the Demora issue,
demore needed to set this thing up at
Google differently.
So I took my son to the local pinball
arcade and just think of it as a bunch
of workstations where nobody's getting
paid.
Instead you're paying for the privilege
of staring at this thing for hours with
the bells and lights,
doing something with balls and
mechanical systems.
There are no.
They're not a lot of women trying to
integrate the pinball arcade because
it's a loser activity.
Right?
That's how they see us for losers.
I play pinball.
I'm a loser.
I know these things.
Okay.
Now my owns a pinball arcade,
was kind of restaurant pinball and the
second to hurt me.
No,
I'm just joking.
The point is this is something which has
low prestige.
It's anti compensated and compensated.
Good.
Could we appointing right?
It's just like you're just plugging the
money into the machines.
So my point is is that what you said was
it's not cognitive ability.
You Idiots.
It's interest in temperament,
which is hugely liberating,
right?
If it's not basically cognitive ability.
If men are as smart as women,
but men can do something for hours and
hours often uncompensated in a kind of
robotic monomaniacal tunnel focus kind
of a way.
Is that necessarily a great thing but
happens to be compensated now?
It's only a great thing if that's what
you choose to go into for a career.
I don't.
I program and I hate it.
I'm not programming.
What do you want to do?
Play
that funky Indian violent thing.
Exactly.
But I'll spend hours doing something
like that.
Right,
but the point is is that coding turns me
into like this autistic spectrum.
He guy.
I get speech APP apnea.
Again,
I don't want to say anything against.
The more you get into coding,
you just sort of adopt a code mine,
so he started talking to me while I'm
coding.
Right.
You say,
Hey Eric,
do you want to go out for a beer?
I'll start say
maybe
later.
Yeah.
What I'm doing is I'm being annoying and
I'm distracting you from your.
Exactly.
Right.
I see you as annoying.
Yes.
I'm.
I'm trying to follow something as
annoying too,
if that helps.
Well,
if it's,
if you're doing Brazilian Jujitsu and I
come in and say,
hey joe,
you want to go out for a beer?
Like I got my hands full choked,
bro.
Yeah,
yeah.
So you know,
the.
The issue is that a lot of us,
you know,
who have male hardware,
male software,
recognize that we get obsessive
compulsive.
We're not always thinking about reward.
Right.
It's not necessarily the most attractive
set of characteristics.
When I do math,
I'm definitely wildly on the spectrum
and I'm proud by the way,
I'm proud of it.
It's not like it's not a derogatory
term.
And you're actually talking about
yourself when I'm socializing.
Yes.
I'd like to think that I'm fairly
normal,
fairly normal,
but when I'm doing math,
yeah,
I don't want to be right.
I want,
I want to kill that problem.
I want to think through that thing.
I want to have that theorem.
I'm not on the spectrum in any way,
but I'm that way with writing for sure.
If I'm writing and someone came over to
talk to me and be like,
ah,
I can't talk,
you know,
I'm in my own.
My wife will come over and she'll say,
wow,
you're really sharp with me.
Huh?
What?
I barely even noticed that you were.
Oh,
she's needy.
No,
but the thing is,
is that we've collaborated on.
She brought a geometry from quantum
field theory into economics and so at
the level of,
you know,
she,
she's really,
she occupies brain space with me,
but she will kick out of that space if
the kids need something.
Whereas I'll just say,
I'm sure the kids will be fine.
Just,
you know,
they're two years old,
Eric,
you know,
they're,
they're not going to be able to take
care of themselves,
you know,
and,
and so she'll have a much more.
She always has her compassion running.
Whereas I can turn it off,
turn it on for periods of time when I'm
focused.
There are these differences and you
know,
I think we need to impart to teach women
how to under deliver under deliver.
Yeah.
How so?
Well,
if you can't risk underdelivering then
you can't shoot for the,
you know,
you can't swing for the fences as often.
You want to make sure that you're going
to be able to not disappoint.
Some men very often like,
hey,
I thought I could do it.
Didn't quite work out.
It's going to take another couple of
weeks.
That's a weird way of putting it though,
because that's a results oriented way of
putting them instead of an ambition
oriented.
This is what I'm trying to say.
Like if the real secret of life is over,
promise over deliver,
I don't think it is though,
some that it is assumed that you were in
a bid.
If somebody else is going to promise
more than you,
and then if you can't overdeliver,
given that you've already over promised,
then you can't actually delight people
so that they're going to want to do
multiple,
uh,
go rounds with economy of bullshit
though.
Like,
do we really want even promote that?
Like why not just why,
why not?
Just be honest about what you can do
because you don't know what you can do.
You know,
this is the thing that I will be honest
about what you think you can do.
No,
no.
Okay.
Well,
let's use it in a practical sense like
so.
So this was the whole Watson to bring
you a car and I say,
hey man,
I think the transmission's gone on his
fucking thing.
Do you not a fixed one of those things
and you're like,
definitely,
I know how to do it.
I can do it.
But meanwhile you don't write well I
don't want to go to you man.
Well I'll go to the guy down the street,
but you've given it to them for 25
years.
He's given me the car right now.
I go home.
I said,
you know what I'm doing?
I'm trying to open this thing.
I don't know,
right?
I better learn transmissions fast.
Right?
So now I go into crazy mode because now
I'm terrified.
This is called crossing the adaptive
value.
What if it's something you can't learn
fast,
like Brazilian Jujitsu?
Look,
what if I come to you and I say,
Hey,
are you a Jujitsu expert,
Eric?
And you're like,
yes I am.
I'm like,
okay,
cool.
Why don't you meet me in two weeks and
we're going to do Jujitsu and you have
two weeks to go fucking crazy and learn
all,
you know about Jujitsu.
So what we're talking about now is this
is not a trivial skill and transmissions
is.
No,
let's slow it down.
Okay?
You have to be able to have a feel for
what adaptive valleys you can cross.
Okay?
I see what you're saying.
So in other words,
if you just say like,
Hey,
I could run this country country,
uh,
I run businesses,
then you're going to have a problem
because you really have to learn
Washington in order to run it.
Right?
And if you have no plan to do that,
then you're just bullshitting your way
through everything.
Like hypothetically.
Yeah,
like this hypothetical situation
hypothetically now.
But my point is that there are lots of
things that don't have those
characteristics were um,
something is really hard,
but you may have to invent something in
order to get out of it.
So there's,
you know,
dumb enough to get in smart enough to
get out is kind of the magic formula.
Hm.
Bite off more than you can chew,
but if you actually,
you know,
feel cold,
you can summon the will,
you can summon the intellect,
you can summon your friends,
your resources to somehow get across the
adaptive value,
but isn't it a problem that it leaves
open?
The possibility won't be able to get
across that valley.
We just put someone who is an expert in
the field and who's worked very hard
through apprenticeship,
through schooling,
whatever it is to get to become an
expert in this field can tell you
definitively,
yes,
Eric,
I can fix your computer.
I've fixed computers for a living.
I know exactly how to attach a
motherboard to let's at least agree that
you're making the point that you know
don't over promise and under deliver.
Yes,
but we all know that.
We all know that.
That's the general good advice.
So,
but you're advising women to do
something that they shouldn't.
But here's the problem.
I'm trying to give advice.
The more women that over promise and
under deliver,
the more people are going to go,
you know,
what are these chicks?
Because they don't deliver.
I don't think that that's right.
You don't think.
I think that what's happening is,
is that there are certain
characteristics that are very valuable
in low variance processes.
There are certain things that you want
every time to work out.
Okay.
Right.
Well,
child,
child rearing or particular kinds of
surgery.
Yes.
Right.
It's a simple APP and a appendectomy.
I,
I don't want to get fancy,
just do the APP and an appendectomy and
don't screw it up.
Right.
Okay.
So those are low variance processes.
Now you've got some sort of crazy
conjoined twins that nobody's ever seen
before.
Right.
And the question is what are we going to
do?
Right.
Well,
do you think that that is potentially
within your ability,
even though nobody's ever successfully
pulled it off before you have to over
promise to some extent.
Like there's a guy who's going to try to
do a head transplant,
you know,
we,
we had somebody who,
a head transplant with monkeys in the
early seventies,
Robert White or something.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
this came out of um,
Jim Watson said this thing,
which I think is just brilliant,
which is if you're going to do something
amazing,
you are by definition unqualified to do
it.
That's Watson and Crick and Watson.
That's right.
Now the point was is that those guys did
not know enough biochemistry to do the
Double Helix,
but why do you think that that's good
advice to give to women to overprice
over promise.
I understand that,
okay.
If you cannot over promise,
you may not be able to win a bidding war
for the right to do a project.
If you're playing it very,
very safe and other people are saying,
yeah,
I can get that done faster and cheaper.
See,
the cynic in me says you're telling
people to bullshit.
I like Bill Gates.
I'd like to know whether or not someone
can actually deliver on what we're
talking about.
When Bill Gates talked to IBM,
he didn't have an operating system.
He said that he did.
That created a panic situation.
How often do you have a product and you
announced the date for the product
before the engineering is done,
but are you talking about outliers?
Then you talking about people that
pulled things off that you know the
average person probably doesn't mean.
How many of you talked about the
wayside.
How many people do over promise and this
is what I'm trying to get at,
which is if you value regularity,
then under promise over deliver,
right?
If you value shackleton like outliers,
you may have to over promise and over
deliver.
So wait,
wait,
wait.
Okay.
Let's go ahead and you may have to risk
over promising and under delivering
another thing.
Women are averse to that.
Oh absolutely.
So women are averse to bullshitting
people.
Absolutely they are.
I like,
I'm not hiring chicks.
I'm gonna start hiring chicks for the
reason you're telling them to not be the
way they are,
but we're failing to communicate show.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just.
I'm just playing devil's advocate and
picking you apart a little bit.
That's okay.
But I think in other words,
when when you start hearing people say,
why aren't there more female founders of
a billion dollar plus tech companies,
my feeling is that a lot of those people
who do found such companies are in this
kind of fast and loose outlier idiom and
very often females specifically because
of the crazy demands of child rearing,
which is something you cannot screw up.
You have to be on all the time.
You have to be incredibly regular,
have a very strong ethic of not screwing
up branches positive.
I don't want to say that it's negative,
right?
I'm not saying that it's negative.
What I am saying is that if you are not
happy because you were not represented
in the outlier category,
understand that not screwing up is not a
behavior pattern that leads to outlier
level results.
I see what you're saying.
So they almost have to go away from
their natural instincts in adopt a
different pattern or behavior to achieve
extraordinary success.
I mean,
I would like to tell a lot more men,
hey,
you can't keep promising and failing to
come through.
So you know,
it would be better if we had higher
regularity from some men who chronically
over promise and chronically under
deliver and we had more women who were
trying to swing for the fences.
If the feeling is why are we not
represented at the highest level of
certain kinds of activities.
So all right,
so what I'm trying to get at is,
is that we are not currently feeling
safe enough to have these style of
conversations where we're saying,
look,
to what extent are we holding ourselves
back?
Are we holding you back?
What is it that we need to be doing?
Or are we talking about the glass floor
as well as the glass ceiling.
So know the brick layer
unions.
The is a famous example where if you
look for pictures of brick layers,
you'll generally see a bunch of guys,
a very few women and there is no
complaint that these have not been
integrated.
So there are ways in which you don't
find women in the pinball arcades,
you don't find them in brick layers
unions and you find fewer of them
founding,
you know,
multibillion dollar tech companies.
So how do we feel about that?
I don't know.
I mean,
the key question is if you want to see
change,
you have to be risking having a real
conversation about these things.
And what demore tried to do was to
decouple intelligence from this problem
and say it's much more temperament and
interest.
And the person who made that point on
Dave Rubin show a month before the
Google memo leak was my wife and she
didn't get attacked because she said,
look,
you know,
I was in an incredibly,
basically an all male environment.
I wasn't happy because of the
temperament and interest when it got
highly competitive.
Uh,
I didn't want to spend my energy and my
time fighting.
No,
she has,
she has like a Nobel quality result in
economics.
And her feeling was it's just not worth
it to get into some multi-decade pissing
match with incredibly powerful people.
Now,
my feeling about this is those guys are
going down.
We're gonna fight them.
You know,
I read my book,
came out called the physics of Wall
Street that I encourage women to read
the chapter called a new Manhattan
project.
And the epilogue discusses her
contribution,
uh,
and you know,
in fact we sort of walked away from it
in part because she didn't want to go to
war and there's nothing wrong with not
wanting to go to war,
but that is a very big,
temperamental difference that is not a
cognitive difference.
And that's what I think the more we're
saying now,
I think you and I would both agree that
we would never want anyone to
discriminate against women for a job
they're qualified for and that they're
looking to get into.
If they're good at it,
we would like to see people who would
like to see in a quality of opportunity.
Right.
More than that.
Yeah.
I mean if you think about how many women
are offline and you think of it as like,
just stop thinking about in terms of
social good.
And think about it as like when you like
an oil field that hasn't been tapped,
just their neuro field.
See what you're saying is essential.
Yeah.
Right.
Like,
you know,
you're just talking about Jews and
physics.
So one quarter of one percent of the
world's population of 1:25
percent of the Nobel prizes in physics
or thereabout.
Right?
Very few Asian females have Nobel
prizes.
If,
if I were trying to figure out,
like with oilfields,
I wouldn't go to Texas to try to find
more oil because I'd figured pretty well
picked over.
I'd try find some other place.
It's like I'm going to find great waves.
Not In Hawaii,
but I'm going to go to the Arctic,
right?
So let's say Asian females have a huge
percentage of the world's neurons
basically untapped.
If you want to make tons of money,
if you want to cure cancer,
if you want to do all these things,
figured out how to bring those neurons
fully online.
So it's not just a question of nobody
wants to keep them out.
There's a huge prize to be won for
figuring out the puzzle.
Right?
But it has not been proved that gender
and sex have a role in what people are
attracted to,
are interested in.
So why should we assume that just
because we have these systems,
whether they're economic systems,
whether it's,
um,
you know,
starting a business or whether it's
working in tech,
why should we assume that women would
want to do that?
Why should we encourage them to do that
if they're not interested in it and why
do we put so much value in it just
because it generates incredible amount
of money.
Do you think that maybe what we're
looking at is natural patterns?
There's natural patterns where,
I mean this is what demore argued,
that men gravitate towards certain
things more often than women.
And that was one of the things that was
so disturbing to me that was overlooked
about his memo.
He had a full page and a half dedicated
to trying to encourage and various ways
to try to encourage women to get into
tech.
Right?
Nobody talked about that.
The other thing that they didn't do is
no one,
not no one,
but many of the people that read
published his work and took snippets of
it.
They didn't publish the citations or the
Bibliography,
which is like Reno.
It's immoral,
but it's what it is,
is back to your analogy.
Yeah,
these people are in a cult and this was
a challenge to,
to the ideology of the cult,
so no,
but
look,
let's look at it from the felt
experience in the felt experience is if
you're,
if you've already struggled as a woman
against incredible odds to be in tech to
begin with,
you know that there's somebody
whispering.
Yeah,
she's not very good.
They only hired her because she was
female and you're sick of this shit.
Right?
So you have to appreciate that.
The lived experience of the women inside
of Google is that they know that some
percentage of those guys were saying,
Hey,
I just want to talk about studies are
actually pissed off.
Right?
So their bullshit detectors are set
very,
very high.
They think they're hearing dog whistles
everywhere.
Right?
And so I don't think we should be
blaming women who have been subjected to
this as if this is not a real thing.
There really are dog whistles.
There really are people who don't want
women in tech and want to go back to an
all boys club,
blah,
Blah Blah for sure.
But that's not really what we're saying.
No,
we aren't,
I don't think.
No,
but the issue is what if I need to do
some amount,
some relatively minimal amount of um,
kind of intellectual terraforming to get
all of these female neurons to work on
all of these amazing problems.
So what if,
what if the people who have the answer
for let's say cancer or Agi or who
knows,
happened to be female [inaudible],
what if I needed to do some things in
order to make the environment more
attract?
Like for example,
programming in teams has to some extent
per replaced.
Cowboy programming was just some guy
with his code and you know,
a set of headphones and he,
he goes to it.
Okay.
So that's what he was talking about.
Like what are the,
to what extent can you actually change
the nature of work to bring these extra
neurons online now that's the right
reason to do this.
I don't think we should value like what
is coding?
It's some sort of highly logical,
very technical persnickety activity if
it's highly compensated,
everybody wants in.
If it's poorly compensated,
only people who are sort of addicted to
it would want it.
Right.
And it happens to be sort of high status
at the moment.
And so there's this feeling of,
okay this must be an all boys club and
maybe it grew up as an all boys club and
maybe it has particular attributes,
but the thing that I,
I'm looking at maybe different from what
you're looking at is that I'm thinking
about particular high ability females
who have left the game or who have sort
of gone into a lower intensity mode
because there's just sick of being in an
all male environment.
So if I can interject,
you try and discourage attrition.
I'm trying to discourage attrition of
the amazing people who have something
deep and powerful and important to say.
So the environment of these places is
contrary to them establishing whatever
strengths.
So let me give.
I would rather not talk about women and
I'd rather talk about something I know
very,
very well,
which is myself.
Okay.
So four and a half years ago I gave some
talks on physics,
um,
which were terrifying to me because I
wasn't trained as a physicist and they
got a lot of attention and publicity at
Oxford.
I don't like the unpleasantness of
intellectual oneupsmanship and negging,
if you will,
that takes place in particle theory.
It's a turn off to me.
And so I've sort of stayed away for four
and a half years because I didn't like
how unpleasant and hyper like
exaggeratedly masculine it was.
Why do you think that exists?
Well,
because it's a huge prize,
right?
I mean,
if you're trying to get,
gain Einstein's mantle,
um,
it's still a game worth winning because,
you know,
Einstein was times out of the century.
So it's still because of this huge
prize,
there's also a lot of critical thinking
and a lot of criticizing.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of just wasted.
There's like a Dick measuring contest
that does nothing for me.
Hmm.
Okay.
Right.
And
so,
so my point is,
is that is a guy who's been in
mathematics,
physics,
economics,
finance,
and tech.
That's five hyper male fields.
There are some of them that I just can't
stand because there two exaggeratedly
male and you feel like criticism is
exaggeratedly male,
not just criticism,
it's just like snarky,
stupid,
mean spirited,
nonconstructive main girl show,
female show,
maybe housewives of Beverly Hills.
That's pretty pretty.
Take downy.
Yeah.
That's a different version.
So um,
this is made you avoid these particular
person makes lots of us men and women
there would be more likely to avoid and
you would lose the contribution trying
to sell a lot of these brilliant minds.
That part of the problem is,
is that every time you have an extremely
kind of overly like an exaggeratedly
toxic culture,
you get attrition from people who are
really good at it or just don't like to
go into work.
It makes sense.
And putting that on women is not fair.
Right?
I don't want to do labor economics at
Harvard for the same reason.
It's a really unpleasant.
I understand that once they've actually
gotten to the game,
but is that what keeps them from
pursuing the game or is it natural
inclinations towards other pursuits?
I believe it's a mixture.
It's a mixture.
Most things,
right?
Well this is,
this is really what,
what Demora was saying.
He was saying there's a 50 slash 50
default baseline that you've adopted.
I don't think I.
Ju,
I James Damore don't think that we
should accept 50 slash 50.
We should figure out what percentage of
this has to do with um,
interest and inclination.
Um,
and that should be an adjustment and
that we're sending tests do with
prejudice and.
Right.
So break it into two components were off
of 50 per,
it's a plus b,
where a is the natural amount that it,
it should favor one gender or sex over
the other.
And then b is the extent of systematic
bias.
That's a very analytical and I think a
very.
I think it's exactly what he was saying
is exactly right.
You're one of the very few people that
has broken down like that.
It became this weird ideological
struggle,
but I got into tremendous trouble
because I let off a tweet that was about
biologists,
right?
Because Richard Dawkins had just been
deep platformed at Berkeley where he was
going to speak as a biologist.
My brother.
Yeah.
What was that about?
Why did they do platform?
Because you know,
he said something on charitable about
Islam,
which means we have to get back to.
Right.
But the key point was is that I had
three biologists to more Dawkins and
Weinstein who had all been d platform,
so I let off a tweet about,
you know,
for God's sake,
stop teaching people that they should
run to hr,
um,
rather than code,
which had nothing to do with harassment
at all.
It was really just about seeing
a woman,
uh,
who deleted her tweet.
I haven't talked about this until now
because I,
I felt that I,
I reacted to her deleted tweet and then
I still,
I still have it on my computer,
but I didn't want to bring it up.
And then I was left holding the bag.
Right.
Um,
what was the tweet?
It was something like,
dear Google,
I don't teach my daughter to run to hr
for financial freedom rather than code.
Thanks a dad.
And that was interpreted as like,
oh,
suck it up.
If you're being harassed in the
workplace,
you know,
do not suck it up.
If you were being harassed in the
workplace,
I don't know how to make that clearer,
but it's about if somebody is talking
like a biologist and they're saying,
oh,
well there's pre prenatal testosterone
and um,
you know,
they're the psychometrics and there,
these are the conserved differences
across cultures.
That's not a reason to go to hr.
That's a reason to figure out whether
the person is making sense,
not making sense to take them on,
in the arguments.
Um,
that's,
I feel very passionately that discourse
and free speech is incredibly important.
When you,
you distort what that guy was saying and
you turn it into this hateful attack on
women.
You've shut down discourse and you
discourage anybody else that has any
sort of unusual opinion or unusual
observation from coming forth because
you're essentially,
you're limiting free speech to free
speech that you agree with.
And this is what happened while I agree
with this,
but think about how difficult it has
been.
You know,
as soon as I say,
learn how to over promise and over
deliver on risk under delivering that,
that,
that can take up 10 minutes.
Like,
are you telling me to bullshit and not,
not come through?
No,
I'm not saying that what I'm saying,
but all of these higher level points all
have lower level misinterpretations.
Right?
And so in this circumstance,
it's also important to realize that
after so many years of putting up with
sort of whisper campaigns,
it is understandable that women are sick
of this shit.
Right?
So that's true to that too.
So the key question is,
are we going to just deep platform all
the biologists,
are we going to pretend that there are
no differences?
Are we going to pretend that gender and
sex have absolutely nothing to do with
each other?
Like this sort of fantasy life that you
can try to lead a in a progressive
context is going to destroy the
underpinnings of Western civilization.
And I have nothing against eastern
civilization,
but I'm an exponent of Western
civilization.
Yeah.
And you know,
this gets back to the issue of will we
be able to talk anywhere in a safe
enough fashion that we can have really
meaningful conversations so that we can
actually fix these fucking problem.
Right.
And the only way you're going to fix
these problems is if you cut out all
this,
the,
the ideological biases
on the right and the left,
uh,
the male and the female,
and just look at the problem for what it
really is.
Well,
and it's tough and we're challenged
because we also don't see ourselves,
but just firing that guy for that memo.
And then here's the,
my favorite part of my all time favorite
part.
They invited women to take time off
because it was so stressful.
I mean,
you are,
you are reinforcing the worst
stereotypes that someone couldn't ever.
You've actually read the memo and it was
so disturbing to you that you had to
take time off.
You are insanely fragile or you're
looking for time off.
You're looking to take time off.
Either one of those things reinforces
the worst stereotypes that people have
against women.
Yeah,
but what if the idea is different?
What if the idea is that they've
actually been experiencing trauma at
somebody else's hands?
That wasn't James Demore.
Okay,
but that's not about the James Damore
memo and I have it done right?
Why have it?
But you're having it directly in
response to that guy's a memo,
which wasn't in any way derogatory
conversation.
I go to India and I see a bunch of
backwards swastikas with dots and then
that have nothing to do with Nazis.
Right.
I'm a fucking triggered when we're going
far though.
We're pretty far away from that.
Let's just talk about the internal memo
that Google sense like why?
Why give women off if you.
Well,
first of all,
don't fire that fucking guy.
Have a conversation with them and have
open discourse.
The biggest problem was firing because
that establishes the precedent.
That truck look.
I called him up specifically to ask what
the hell happened?
And you know you've talked to him.
Yes.
He's soft spoken.
Very kind,
very nice guy.
James is pretty open so I'm going to say
he's wildly introverted,
almost certainly on the spectrum for
sure.
And his reaction was that I went to a
meeting where they tried to teach
diversity.
The biology was wrong.
They asked if I had any feedback.
I told them and he wrote an 18 page man,
but don't write this.
This is how his brain thinks,
which is why he's a coder,
which is why he was a biologist,
which is why champion the right,
exactly.
This is how it's very important that
these people not be made unwelcome
because fundamentally we're going 11
this untried social justice stuff in
absolutely every well.
Not only that,
he was labeled as a misogynist over and
over and over again,
and you don't even giving the guy a
chance to have a communication.
We have open communication like if you
sit down with them instead of firing.
Problem is,
is that if you say,
come to the seminar,
we're going to teach you things.
The things are wrong and now we want
your feedback.
You're just setting certain minds up for
this thing for sure.
That said,
and this is something I,
I,
this is much harder to bring to this
room,
this room,
this room.
What's wrong with,
you know,
because I'm,
I'm part of this constellation of
people,
but we keep doing this.
We keep making a mistake in my opinion,
which is we
keep seeing these wrong things that
happen in the space and we lose the
empathy in some sense because people are
not representing themselves well,
so I believe having watched my wife and
economics,
that it is really corrosive to go in
everyday to work in an environment which
does not feel welcoming.
Right?
For sure.
Very toxic,
very bad for now.
The idea is that something breaks the
camel's back and it's approximate cause
it's not the actual problem.
Right.
On how they framed it,
they're saying they're giving people
time off because there's diversity memos
that he targets versus hard targets.
Right?
So the idea is is that he was a soft
target,
but they may have had,
you know,
many of these women may have had a
manager who passed them over for
promotions three times when they'd been.
The major contributors sort of
reinforces a rational ideas about his
memo without actually reading the core
components of it and look at objects.
Why I.
that's why I was outspoken on the point
is even well,
I am outspoken on demaurice.
Think there's issues that believed are
fundamentally,
we are in danger of breaking empathy
with people who do not express
themselves at our idiom.
And I don't like the fragility,
I don't like the,
you know,
there's this confusion between strong
people versus very aggressive people and
in general,
stronger people are much less
aggressive.
Right?
Isn't that,
that's like loud yelling.
People think that they're winning an
argument because they're loud and
yelling.
Well,
if you watch like the jungle book,
Shere Khan,
the tiger is portrayed as unfailingly
polite,
right?
Because he's just,
he doesn't need to prove himself.
Right?
So part of the problem is,
is that we are waiting for the strongest
voices to rise above the din and say,
look,
we can't be this aggressive about
everything all the time.
Right?
We have to actually think what's a
misdemeanor,
a felony,
what's a foot fault?
You know?
So just to boil it all down,
you don't think there's any issue with
inviting women to take time off from a
memo that you didn't even disagree with?
Um,
I absolutely think that there's a
problem there,
but I don't think that that's the right
place.
Google sitting on a pile of cash.
It doesn't need all these people to show
up.
They botched this thing as far as I can
tell.
But why?
Why tell women take some time off?
You just got assaulted.
You were just attacked by some horrible
thing that doesn't discourage or that
discourages diversity.
That discourages the right thing to do,
would be to retain demore.
Right?
And to say,
look,
we need to be able to talk about this
without silencing each other with that
terrifying each other without assuming
that we've heard the other's argument.
Perhaps some public speeches where you
have people opposes ideas and have them
discuss.
Right.
And,
and make it public so that maybe people
can learn from it instead of making it
this gigantic campaign against one guy's
idea and just destroying his credibility
in a very sort of perverse way.
How about just google has youtube,
they have all the resources in the world
to turn this into an educational
experience.
Exactly.
Yeah.
But the big problem was firing demore.
Yes,
I agree with what that did was it puts
out a precedent,
said,
here's how this game should go.
When you hear somebody say genotype
versus phenotype complain.
Yes.
When you.
When something makes you uncomfortable
about psychometrics complaint,
if somebody starts to agree with the
implicit association tests and they
won't own their own bigotry and bias
complain.
Right?
Well that's terrifying.
Well,
it's sort of the same type of thinking
that got your brother in hot water in
Evergreen,
but what I'm trying to get at is that we
are,
we who understand this problem,
I think better than others and are
willing to talk about it in public,
are losing empathy because we're so sick
of being worn down by these terrible
arguments.
Right.
And so,
you know,
can we,
can we pop all the way back up to your
original point about Islam?
Sure.
Okay.
You asked the question why does the left
seemingly weirdly supportive of
practices that include female genital
mutilation,
honor,
killing a terror,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And I think it has to do with the fact
that there is a fundamental inability to
discuss these issues because nobody has
given us the right tools and language.
So the issue of Political Judaism,
political Christianity in political
Islam is one category.
And then there's just sort of cultural
Judaism,
cultural Islam,
Cultural Christianity.
Now quite honestly,
um,
you can easily be embedded in a Muslim
community that is not devoted to
political Islam and feel that you're
very much in another abrahamic faith
similar to Christianity and Judaism.
On the other hand,
there is a much bigger issue,
which is that Islam has a totality to it
that Judaism no longer has and that
Christianity perhaps never had a Sam
Harris points the out the line render
unto Caesar what is Caesar's,
um,
cleaves off the potential for political
Christianity at the same level as
political Islam.
So you're dealing with this different
object that doesn't quite seem to have
the same characteristics as the others.
And you haven't been given tools to sort
of pull it apart.
You've also been taught that if you're
proud of European civilization,
um,
that you are like pro white,
a white is irrelevant to me.
I care about European civilization just
as I care about European barbarity
having sat through European barbarity.
I'm not gonna give up on European
civilization.
Um,
you know,
so in,
in part what you have is you have people
who are making the vanilla confusion
where they imagine that vanilla,
you know,
we use it to mean the absence of
anything interesting,
but in fact it's like the most
interesting spice.
And it's this,
it's this particular orchid that's
incredibly flavorful.
So it's like a linguistic mistake.
Well,
white is that to European civilization.
I have no attachment to my whiteness.
I could care less,
couldn't care less.
On the other hand,
I have a huge attachment to Newton,
to Mozart to the terrible things that
happened,
uh,
you know,
in the,
in the killing lands in the mid 20th
century.
Um,
so the evil,
the good,
the imperialism,
the guilt,
like that tradition.
I'm very resonant with the good,
the bad and the ugly.
And it is my tradition.
So when I meet somebody coming from
China,
I expect them to be an exponent of
Chinese culture.
Well,
I don't wish to say,
well,
I don't have the right to have my own
culture because I have to erase myself.
Um,
based on this confusion between this
Canon that is incredibly value will and
the skin color that is completely
irrelevant to me.
I don't,
I would much rather have western
civilization running between the ears of
people who don't look anything like me
and,
you know,
be proud of what the software has
produced.
Um,
then,
uh,
have a bunch of people who look like me
who don't think in any way that I
recognize wherever the original point
was.
Why does the left wider progressive's
fail to criticize the homophobia,
the sexism,
the,
the honor killings,
all the horrific acts.
So let's talk about.
Let's talk about a particular example.
Rolla.
Have you ever heard of him?
Yes.
Revolutionary Afghan Women's
Association.
These are the,
these are the most bad ass chicks on the
planet.
They are the ones who taught little
girls under the Taliban.
They are Muslim,
they are proud Afghan women.
Uh,
they have Afghan men who risked their
lives.
These are people who take their lives in
their own hands to educate women.
And one of the most repressive places on
earth that is Islam.
Those are Muslims right now.
My point is I try to get people
interested in,
won't you take the side of the Muslims
who hold your values or the values
closest to yours?
And this is where we get into trouble
because for some reason we don't
perceive that there is almost an
intellectual civil war within Islam with
forces for modernity and forces that are
trying to reboot a,
you know,
from original texts.
Right.
So do you think that we associate Islam
with maybe even a smaller faction of it
than we really understand like the isis
faction,
the,
the Taliban like thing,
things that were terrified of.
Well,
people that are throwing gay folks off
buildings,
we saw how weirdly view them as more
authentic.
Mm.
Um,
in some sense.
And so you don't want to go against the
authentic in aversions,
but like for example,
the hobbyist,
a sort of Saudi Arabian variant I never
thought was going to be influential over
Pakistan because South Asians tended to
look down.
Um,
but with,
you know,
all of this money that's been spent a
exporting the sort of,
um,
particularly text oriented,
very literal interpretations.
Uh,
I think we've,
we've gone down a terrible path where
we've sort of,
weirdly,
I'm not understood that there is a
conflict and that we actually have a dog
in this fight,
in the dog,
in this fight is a,
those who are trying to create cultural
Islam and cleaving off political Islam.
I don't want to live under Sharia law
and I don't want to feel bad about this.
I don't want to live under anybody's
religious law.
I don't want anyone to live under
Halakhic Jewish law.
And this is a mainstay of Western
civilization.
And when we can't feel comfortable about
that,
which is like,
well,
who are you to say whether we should
live in under sharia?
Law?
Answer is,
I come from a culture myself.
It's not like I have no culture,
this is my culture.
We do not live under religious law
period.
The end.
It's fascinating to me how very how many
different ID allowed ideologies exist
and how much they vary in how people can
just slot right into those and accept
them as the end all be all period and
it's to me,
just from a evolutionary psychology
standpoint,
just looking at the broad spectrum of
different ideologies that people slot
into.
It's so fascinating.
It's so fascinating how many different
mindsets that people adhere to that are
unwavering and rigid and how common it
is.
It's so uncommon to not have an
ideology.
I mean,
it seems like this idea of what will
will the numbers that we have of
atheists and agnostics in America today,
I mean,
is this unprecedented?
Is this the most,
the largest group of human beings ever
that are looking at things and going,
maybe nobody has the answer.
Maybe this isn't the right way.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
but I also think that a lot of those
agnostics and atheists have more
religious leanings than they'll open up
to and a lot more of the folks
are able to run the atheist agnostic
program almost perfectly,
uh,
between their ears as well.
I don't think it's as clean as let's
say,
you know,
Sam [inaudible],
Sam Harris might make a difference what
I was going to get to next.
Why is it that so many people who are
atheists and agnostics adopt religious
tendencies in terms of cultural behavior
and what they're willing to accept and
not willing to set,
except a lot of the stuff that you see
that you're calling earlier when you
were saying people that describe racism
and you know,
do,
do you describe it as power and
influence these cult member ideas?
You're a lot of times getting these cult
member ideas from people that will tell
you that they're not a part of an
ideology.
They're not religious,
but they're exhibiting dogmatic
religious ideology.
So that was my question is,
is it just a,
a thing that we are inherently
programmed to slot into?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This is,
this is the big point where when Jordan
Peterson and Sam Harris got into it the
first time on Sam show that was so
confused and it was,
well,
it was confusing and Sam would have,
would have appeared to have won that one
pretty decisively because Jordan tried
to fold in fitness to the definition of
truth.
She does not work,
right?
Jordan's point,
however,
was really deep and I don't think he did
it,
uh,
the service it needed to be to have
done.
I think there would have been better off
in person.
I don't like conversations where people
are talking on skype and I've refused so
far to do any podcast where I'm not
looking at the person because I believe
that the eye contact too.
Yeah,
it's huge.
I've done one so far that it was with
John Anthony West,
that brilliant egyptologist and it just
because he's was ill and he lives in New
York and it's just hard to get.
It was awkward.
Yeah,
I do it if I had to.
But in general,
it's like how many fights have happened
over unicode and asked exactly just bad
message board fights,
how many of them would even take place
when you were looking at each other,
talking to each other.
Tone,
tone,
social cues is.
It's completely with video conferencing
is that you find that you're staring
right above the person's eyes.
So there's no trust.
Yes.
So it's weird.
But what I was going to say is that
Jordan Peterson's really deep point is,
if I understand it.
So Jordan,
if you're out there,
please correct me.
I'm his only archetype of the kind found
in religion is sufficiently rich and
deep to explain why humans behave the
way they do.
There's no scientific theory that's good
enough.
There's no purely logical.
There's no purely philosophical
tradition.
So as of the moment we're stuck with
deep cultural archetype.
Maybe Shakespeare would be the only
thing comparable to the religious
cannons and the claim that you're making
implicitly in the Jordan is making
perhaps more explicitly is that there's
something about our brains maybe that we
were parented and so we need to give the
parenting apparatus over to something
else.
I don't know.
That fundamentally finds its way to
religion.
Even if the computer that is our brain
knows that it's making leaps that don't
make sense.
How old are your kids?
Mine are 12 and 15.
Do you,
when you see them,
do you see things that are you and your
wife and wonder like,
is this,
how much of this is genetics?
How much of this is them mimicking their
environment?
How much of it as both.
And then there's the Sui generis stuff
that comes from God knows where that I
have no idea cut into their head at all.
Well,
culture,
the uh,
books and I mean don't,
don't discount individual invention.
Sure.
For sure.
That too.
So I believe that my son who's 12,
I'm has gravitated very strongly towards
Judaism.
Um,
so we go to services.
I don't think he believes in a technical
sense,
but he enjoys the service.
Yeah.
But you know,
again,
so many of us just don't.
Well,
the music is beautiful sentiments.
The richness.
I mean,
coming back to Jordan's point,
it's not.
Part of it was like hearing during a
heart.
All right,
you're in like a star wars drama or
you're in Kung Fu panda and don't let go
to some.
You know,
you're,
you're going to a place whether it's a
temple or a chapel or you know,
you're going to.
This place is uniquely ornate
environment.
You know,
we have particular words.
For example,
the rabbis tell us,
you know,
we usually don't say this because this
is what we have stolen from the angels,
but this was the one time in the year
when we can actually shout it and it's
potent staff potent and you know,
you're gonna to your original point.
So you have some weird tradition that
makes no sense.
That produces it ridiculously
disproportionate number of the Nobel
prizes,
let's say in science.
You would it be scientific to throw that
away?
I don't think so.
No.
Right.
So if you were a good scientist,
you'd say,
I don't know what's going on with these
weird rituals.
It's like,
you know,
it could be the funky chicken,
or the Hokey Pokey,
but something is made,
you know,
if,
if most of the people who win Nobel
prizes were founded to do the Hokey
Pokey,
I'd probably put more effort into it and
maybe it's not.
Maybe it's not attached to the ideas
that spawn from these religions at all.
Maybe it's that these people have the
freedom to think about these other
things because they have intense
confidence in their future and their
destiny and their God and their
traditions and their ethics and their
also carved out that this.
I've always thought of religion in some
ways is almost being like a moral
scaffolding.
Like,
okay,
well you got like a real clear structure
to operate under and that that gives you
resources.
It gives you a frees up resources to do
other things.
I mean,
the problem is is that the atheist
critique,
which is like there is no bearded dude
in a cloud granting your wishes are
listening to what you know,
bitch.
That's my answer to you know,
because everybody who says there's No
God and nothing happens when you die,
like you don't know that to say that as
no different than someone saying they
know for sure there's a god in the cloud
with a harp and St Peter and you to go
look at a list,
but if we conjure art,
if we conjure Sam and we tried to steal
me and sam,
Sam will say,
okay,
but there's all these explicit ways that
you're supposed to worship God.
They can't all be right because they're
mutual incompatibilities and so how do
you choose one among many and if and
left,
okay,
blah,
blah.
None of this is the point.
The point is deep archetype is its own
thing and the mind seeks deep archetype.
It's white cares about the godfather
pictures differently than home alone.
Home alone is not deep archetype,
godfather pictures or deep archetype.
Right?
Okay.
This is why I'm on Kung Fu.
Kung Fu panda,
like white on rice.
That is deep archetypes.
Those are actually pretty God damn good
movies now.
Just the first one.
The second one is not bad.
My kids liked it.
They're younger than yours.
Don't hide behind my kids.
Just I liked it.
I enjoy it.
I enjoyed him.
I enjoyed the lego movies,
man.
I said I've never seen.
All of them are not bad.
This last Ninjago one's not bad.
I enjoy it.
So I think that just messing me.
There's a lot of fucking dumb shit that
I like though.
That said.
Really?
Yeah.
I like it.
A lot of dumb shit musically.
What's some dumb shit that Jaylen Kiss?
That is dumb shit.
Every now and then man,
I'm on my way to the comedy store.
I'll throw on.
I was made for loving you.
It was fun.
Yeah.
That's not so bad.
But I prefer angus young in school.
Boy Pay.
I don't mind it either.
I like him as well.
Yeah.
Look,
I like all kinds of music.
But um,
I,
I wonder when it comes to archetypes,
whether or not when I was getting to,
when I was talking about your sons and
your children,
whether or not their behavior is
genetic,
whether or not it's learned experience,
whether it's a combination of all
things,
how much of what we have is just in
these,
this sort of inclination towards
ideologies is because pretty much
everybody had them for the thousands and
thousands and thousands of years that we
had civilization and we are in some way
shape or form the product of all that
stuff.
Even genetically,
like whatever memories.
I don't totally understand genetics,
but what I do understand is that there's
a lot that we don't know about why ideas
get transferred from father to son,
from children,
from parents to children.
And there's things that get transferred.
Even two adopted kids that come directly
from their parents in a very eerie way
where you go,
well,
where did,
is there some like what?
Our instincts,
why?
Why are children are afraid of spiders
and monsters?
Like what is that?
Is it because at one point in time
someone near them was killed by a big
cat,
you know,
thousands of years ago,
back when we were living in these
environments where we were preyed upon
by predators.
I mean,
what,
what are the reasons why?
And Rupert sheldrake had a great point
about that.
If you talk to children in New York
City,
they're not afraid of child molesters or
murderers or things that they might
encounter a car accidents.
They're afraid of monsters like w why?
What is a monster and that monster may
very well be the memory or the ancient
genetic memory.
I think it's this.
I mean,
I think if you look at,
for example,
the evil stepmother,
oh,
well that's real too,
right?
Okay.
Yeah,
but what was that about?
Probably it had to do with the fact that
the first thing that you want to teach
your children is,
hey,
if I'm not around and daddy remarries
somebody who has no interest in you
genetically,
here's the emergency break glass in case
of emergency plan.
Right?
There's a little of that,
but it's also,
how many times does that play out where
someone has to tell that story because
it's so common.
We all know it.
We all know the story.
I have a good friend of mine who was
essentially tortured by a stepfather or
throughout growing up.
I mean,
it has a horrific life story and it's
just one of a million,
one of millions.
But sometimes what we do is we,
we sort of go obliquely at these things.
So for example,
in Little Red Riding Hood,
um,
you know,
is the Fox Fox or there's the wolf,
sorry,
as a wolf.
A wolf.
The wolf actually wolf stand in.
Well,
I think it's a wolf because throughout
Europe,
fourth fucking thousands of years.
Wolves preyed on the wolf is pretty
creepy in this kind of thing because
wolves are clever,
you know?
Do you know that in Paris,
in I think the early 14 hundreds wolves
killed something.
Like what was the number,
some insane number of people in Paris,
like 14 people were killed by wolves.
No,
I didn't know.
In Paris they're starting to show up in
Paris again.
Okay,
what was her fucking dangerous land?
It will look.
So I think everybody that everybody
respects the wolf,
but they're clever yesterday about
wolves is they.
They have some sort of template for the
better to see you with my dear.
Right?
Because he was being clever mean.
Okay,
but you asked the question about
predators.
Somebody the big bad wolf,
the three pigs.
It's all wolves.
There's a lot of wolves and ancient folk
lore and stay the fuck out of the woods.
It's always stay out of the woods
because there's wolves in the woods,
right?
So what's the woods is in central park?
No,
it's real woods.
People live near the fucking woods.
They weren't new doors and those kinds
of cities.
When they wrote these stories,
when the grimm brothers were around,
there was no central park,
right?
Yeah.
All I'm
suggesting is that a lot of our
information comes coated so that it
doesn't point to directly.
Maybe,
maybe stepmothers.
Zircons and wolves are dangerous.
Stepmothers.
I take no responsibility for this man.
There's a lot of amazing stepmothers.
Now let's say 30 seconds worth of
things.
That's wonderful step,
but there's amazing step mothers,
but there's obviously some monsters.
There's obviously some monster,
but just to your point,
it's not always step mother,
step father.
The question is what happens when Mommy
or daddy remarries?
Sometimes it's awesome.
Right?
Often it's not.
Right.
And why?
Because of this issue about genetic
relatedness.
So sure to you,
to your earlier question,
I was stunned.
I didn't think about 23 and me as a
religious test,
but when I sent my saliva off to be
analyzed,
it came back.
You were a Jew like 98 point six
percent.
Well I didn't.
I didn't know my religion was in my
saliva.
It didn't even occur to me.
Yeah.
But it's a.
But that's the weird thing about Jews,
right?
Is that it's a religion,
but it was also an ethnicity.
Right,
right,
right.
And so the idea is that all of these
rules,
you know,
dietary restrictions or rules for who
gets to Mary,
at what level in the culture,
where do you put your resources?
Are you proselytizing or do you try to
live at steady state?
Do discourage people converting in all
of these things or some sort of toolkit
for living and it has produced more
physicists,
uh,
then,
um,
you know,
outfielders,
right?
So it's not good at everything.
It's good.
Some things at the exclusion of others.
And so the question about how does the
stuff co travel,
it co travels in some way that's very
mysterious,
you know,
do we pass on trauma?
Uh,
I can say in my family for sure that my
family stopped being religious when my
great uncle Sasha was killed right at
the end of World War Two.
And my great grandmother said,
no,
compassionate God would kill somebody so
stupidly,
uh,
who had so much to give to their family
and change the family from some kind of
Orthodoxy to Orthodox atheism.
And then,
you know,
for three generations you have Jews
marrying Jews with nobody believing in
anything.
Why are they continuing to marry Jews?
Why are they celebrating these holidays?
Well,
it's because fundamentally a switch got
flipped,
but my guess is that the Orthodox,
we're always questioning whether there
was a god.
The atheists are always questioning
whether there's a god at some level
because our brains are not just simple
computers to be know,
rid of bias.
They have particular needs.
So my,
my four things that I care about our
truth,
fitness meaning and grace,
all of those tradeoff amongst
each other.
And when I said something like this on
Sam Sam Harris's program,
a lot of the people who wrote in said,
Oh,
you know,
shows that he doesn't care about truth.
And you know,
I,
I felt like no,
it just shows that you guys don't
understand how important.
What is the argument?
I understand the argument,
Sam would like to make an argument that
the better and more rational our
thinking is,
the more it can do everything that
religion once did.
So if you've had a dmt or lsd experience
that can give you meaning and
transcendence,
uh,
you know,
if you can think your way more
accurately through a problem,
that should increase your fitness.
You know,
maybe grace is something that's
independent and you have to figure out
whether that's important to you.
But that's a choice that an,
you know,
an elected.
I'm objective and my belief is that a
lot of these things are actually preset
and that there's more antagonism between
them.
So I,
I think of myself as an atheist,
but it's only because there's a room in
my mind that I try to keep very,
very clean and analytical that I,
I sort of make the first among equals,
but I have needs for these other things.
I haven't,
you know,
there are times when the truth doesn't
give me enough meaning and I'll start
storytelling.
Okay.
You know,
we're,
we're surrounded.
We've got to fight our way out,
you know,
like all that kind of narrative.
So Joseph Campbell's type stuff,
don't you think that there'd been the
end,
there's lessons to be learned in those,
right?
But it's.
And there's meaning in all those stories
and there's a longing that we have for a
lot of those hero's journey type
narratives.
But um,
but truth is significantly more
important than just these lessons that
we learned from hero's journeys.
Like learning the lessons is important.
They're fascinating.
They're interesting.
The stories are amazing.
But what's really going on?
Like what biological processes are
responsible for certain types of
behavior.
You know,
what,
what really is happening to human bodies
under certain conditions.
What is really happening to the earth,
what is really happening as far as the
mail.
Yeah.
My friend Peter Teal critiques me on
this point just as you have where he
says you eric,
under value and underweight the role of
truth,
but I worry that we're not even having a
conversation.
If I think about my personal physics
hero rock,
uh,
who's the coyote came up with the
equation for the electron less well
known than the,
uh,
Einstein equations,
but arguably even more beautiful in
order to predict that he needed a
positively charged in a negatively
charged particle.
And the only two known at the time with
the electron and the Proton to make up,
let's say a hydrogen atom.
Well,
the Proton is quite a bit heavier than
the electronic.
And so he told a story that wasn't
really true where the Proton was the
antiparticle of the electron.
And Heisenberg pointed
out that couldn't be because the masses
are too far off and they'd have to be
equal.
Well,
a short time later,
the anti electron positron that is,
was found,
I guess by Anderson at Caltech in the
early thirties,
and then an anti-proton was created some
time later,
so it turned out that the story had more
meaning than the exact version of the
story.
So the story was sort of more true than
the version of the story that was
originally told.
And I could tell you a similar story
with,
with Einstein.
I could tell it to you with Darwin,
um,
who,
you know,
didn't fully understand the implications
of his theory as is evidenced by his
screwing up a particular kind of orchid,
uh,
in his later work,
not understanding that his theory
completely explained that orchid.
So there's all sorts of ways in which we
get the truth wrong.
The first several times we try it,
but the meaning of the story that we
tell somehow remains intact.
And I think that that's a very difficult
lesson for people who just want to say,
look,
I want to,
you know,
like fineman would say,
look,
if experiment disagrees with you than
you're wrong.
And it's a very appealing story to tell
to people,
but it's also worth noting that
[inaudible] never got a physical law of
nature and it may be that he was too
wedded to this kind of rude judgment of
the unforgiving.
You know,
you can imagine you were to innovate and
in Brazilian Jujitsu the first few times
it might not actually work,
but if you told yourself a story,
no,
this is actually genius,
and it's working,
and you're like,
no,
you just lost three consecutive bouts.
Well,
that may give you the ability to
eventually perfect the move.
Perfect the technique,
even though you were lying to yourself
during the period in which it was being
set up,
it's a little bit like the difference
between scaffolding and a building.
And too often people who are crazy about
truth rejects scaffolding,
which is an intermediate stage in
getting to the final truth.
So well,
the problem with that analogy is that
some techniques work,
but they just don't work for you.
And the reason why they don't work for
you is you don't know them good enough
yet,
right or not.
You can eat that.
Yeah.
We have a problem with that.
Now.
We can just wrap this up if you're that
hungry.
We're on the homestretch,
buddy.
We got seven more minutes.
Can't take it anymore.
I'm sorry.
Insulin lower issues.
I crashed.
Listen,
let me just wrap this up.
Anyway,
this is a.
This was a really fun conversation.
Really feel like that eating that bar.
He definitely has changed the butter.
Crashed it.
I know what you.
You were so hungry.
You had to eat in the middle of talking.
I was told I could go to the bathroom
here to go to.
Well,
he said you could do it for like six
people.
Go fucking crazy when you hear people
chewing on the microphone.
It was the number one thing that people
complain about on this podcast.
I apologize to them.
No worries.
We've had these fight companion podcast
and people fucking potato chips and
they're eating potato chips on the
podcast and I just would get
my twitter would be filled with people
fucking furious so slightly.
No,
America is hang in there too.
Sorry.
You gotta you gotTa.
Be comfortable being uncomfortable like
a couple minutes.
I can do it too.
What I was gonna say is that analogy is
not the best analogy because some things
work.
They just don't work for you.
Like I'm one of the analogies as used in
Brazilian Jujitsu is like someone will
try a technique and it doesn't work for
them,
and they're like,
well that took me.
It's no good.
And I'll say,
okay,
well you know that head kicks work
right?
You've seen people kick people in the
head and knocked them unconscious.
Right.
Okay.
Try to kick me in the head.
Well,
I don't know how to kick people in the
head.
There you go.
Even if I show you how well you're not
gonna be able to do it.
If I show you how to kick people in the
head,
do you think you gonna be able to kick
someone that actually knows how to fight
and ed?
No.
They're going to move that.
They're going to see it coming.
You're gonna.
It's gonna.
Be too slow.
You're not going to have your neural
pathways carved to the point where that
thing just slices right in there.
You're not going to know how to set it
up,
you're not going to have the confidence
and the experience to execute it.
The difference between that and the
truth is very different because it
doesn't require some sort of physical
process for you to master before you can
execute it with sufficient prowess to
actually be successful.
While I think you know,
this has to do with placeholder truth.
Um,
you know,
the famous example of tricky gnosis and
pork,
where if you believe that God hates
those who eat the pig,
do you think that's what that's about?
I think it's about tricking most likely,
right?
Or various other parasites,
Right.
So,
you know how long,
well,
malaria,
right,
bad air,
shellfish,
red tide,
right?
Don't eat shellfish,
So all of these things have to do with,
I'm not quite sure that I can explain to
you why this is a bad thing,
but let's have a placeholder and then
we'll refine it over time.
Come to understand what it is that we're
doing less.
We're rigid with our ideology and we'd
go buy some ancient scripture that
ancient scripture says that anything
with a cloven hooves that eats its own
cud.
You know,
like there's all these weird laws like
this is your,
what are you're allowed to eat.
This is what you're not allowed to eat.
Except that that's very often not how
things work.
So my fear is is that it's a little bit
the emily latella effect on religion
where the atheist concept of a religious
person is usually the sort of robot that
just looks right and in fact,
what you often find is that you're
rewarded for brilliance in a religion by
not having to follow the rules nearly as
closely.
If you become adept at argument,
it's sort of like really Christian
people with a cross tattooed on them.
That could be right and you make some
art.
Well for example,
in Islam contract marriage where you
need to get married for a few hours so
that you can set your urges with your
wife who
then becomes not your wife.
A short time later,
your arbitrage in the letter of the law
against the need.
For some sort of a human realism,
so they have contract marriages where
you're like,
let's get married for a day.
Yeah,
really sweet.
Good move.
I think everybody should do that.
Just to find out what the hell that
person's really like.
You don't know anybody until you
actually marry him.
Once it was shacked up with them and
you're living for awhile and they have
access to your money,
then you want.
Then you get to find out what they're
really like.
One point 6 billion people are
considering your words right now.
I don't know if it's a good thing or a
bad thing.
I do think that.
I don't think that many people live in
this podcast.
We're okay.
You know,
we had a situation I think in,
uh,
in the late [inaudible] in Israel where
people were using bread crumbs to fish,
uh,
as bait.
And the question was,
will,
does that invalidate the entire water
supply of Israel during Passover?
And so rabbi rabbis had to be convened
and if you know,
pay the sufficient amount of money,
genius level rabbis could figure out why
it was okay to drink the water during
Passover.
Right?
So the issue of getting around your own
rules is a time honored religious
tradition where,
you know,
any book that is not a book for,
for living in survival and thriving,
uh,
is consigned to the dustbin of history.
And so the fact that these things have
been around for so long in general means
that they have their own means of
evading these self extinguishing
programs that would seem to doom them.
Well,
some of them,
those self extinguishing programs,
the way they evaded is through fear,
right?
I mean,
isn't that the fear by Isel cheating on
them?
Yeah.
Right.
And so the is of,
you know,
if you attack on Yom Kippor,
uh,
does that mean you can't fight back
because you should.
You're supposed to be atoning for your
sins.
Now,
if you want to survive,
you're going to figure out a way to
fight on Yom Kippor.
Well,
what about Ramadan?
I guarantee you,
nobody,
you know,
if it were so easy to defeat people,
uh,
using their own religious traditions
against them,
uh,
we wouldn't know the name of these
religions and we wouldn't,
we wouldn't know the genius of the
books.
How many did we lose?
How many religions,
if we forgot what they were and be like,
Joe and Ted's excellent religion.
I would ever just didn't make the cut,
you know?
I mean,
how many from epic of Gilgamesh from
those days I would,
I would guess tons.
What'd they call it?
What was the heaven's gate?
Remember the Nike's that killed
themselves when the comment or the self
castrating yeah.
Yeah.
The one guy who led it was a self
cashiering issue with the Shaker
furniture that they were down to like
one or there were three shakers at some
point.
Then there was like one and they were
accepting.
No note,
no new recruits.
My favorite is the amish.
They have that a,
is that called Rom scholar?
What does that crazy thing go nuts.
They go nuts for like a year from spring
it out is.
That was one year where they just
go fucking hog wild.
They don't have to follow the rules,
and then they usually feel so lost and
disconnected that they,
they.
I think the majority of them returned to
being amish.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure find their way to
burning man.
No,
I don't think they go that kind of now,
so I think it's more like booze and ACDC
type nuts.
They just fuck a lot and get crazy and
throw rocks.
You know what I'm going to.
I'm going to look for the Amish camp
next year.
Eric.
This is a really beautiful conversation.
Exceeded my expectations.
I really enjoyed it and we should do
this more often,
Joe.
Thanks for a terrific.
Thanks man.
All right folks.
We'll be back tomorrow with the great
and powerful Christina possessed ski.
Who's Netflix special is out today.
Hey.